GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
JULY TWENTIETH MEETING. OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. I THINK
WE'VE JUST GOTTEN OF MEMBERS TO
ESTABLISH A CORE MADAM SO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO YOUR DEEP CLEAR.
GABRIEL AREA KILEY. LIMON BONTA
QUIRK SILVA. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
A QUORUM SO WHAT OTHER NUMBER
THINGS I'M GOING TO READ FOR
THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND
PROCEDURE TODAY OUR FIRST ONE
WANT TO THANK ALL THE STAFF WHO
MADE A RETURN TO THE CAPITAL TO
HEAR BILLS CIVIL. DO THE
CONTINUE STATE ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SIR ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASS BE
WARM AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE TO
BE MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC OR TESTIFYING.
WEATHER HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT
A VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF
YOU DON'T HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. IT IS NOW
THE CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF OUR
HOUSE. THAT MEMBERS BE PROPERLY
ATTIRED AND THAT MEANS FOR
HEARINGS WEARING MASKS- WHICH
IS A REQUIREMENT OF BEING
PROPERLY ATTIRED. NOW WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM HERE AND ROOM FORTY TWO OH
TWO. WE CAN ONLY COME TO
ACCOMMODATE THE MINIMUM
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND THE
PUBLIC AND THE MEDIA. TO
MAINTAIN SIXTY THE SPACING.
THERE'S ALSO A STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SAME FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY THE
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. ALAS THE PUBLIC NOT
TO TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. AND
ONCE YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING
PLEASE EXIT THE HEARING ROOM OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. AND PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
WITHIN OUR BUILDING INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE ALSO
HAVE SOME WITNESSES MAKING USE
OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS. WHICH ARE
LOCATED IN THE CAPITAL OR AT
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS OR OTHER
LOCATIONS AROUND THE STATE. OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
HERE IN THE CAPITAL IS ROOM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. DOES WITH THIS
WILL APPEAR ON THIS SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE
FROM OUTSIDE THE HEARING ROOM
AND ALSO HAS SOME QUESTIONS.
NOW WE ALSO WITNESSES WERE
DIALING IN. WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING. IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
THE CALL IN NUMBER THE HEARING.
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU'LL
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON THE
TELEVISION SCREEN. IF YOUR
COMMENT PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO IS
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN Q. BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORTER OPPOSE ADULT. IF
YOUR CALL IN AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND ANY OTHER SMART
DEVICE TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO KNOW
THAT IF YOUR MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL. YOU WILL
REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE AND
YOU'LL NEED TO MEET YOURSELF
UNTIL. YOU'RE CALLED ON SPEAKER
AFTER YOU SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED SERVICE YOU CAN CALL.
MY COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO EIGHT
FIVE AND MY STAFF CAN HELP.
ALSO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON OUR
HOUSING COMMITTEES WEBSITE. AND
I JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS. TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA
WHILE ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT WE ALL FACE A
WITH THAT. ONE WE FIRST TAKE
THE- OF ITEM WE ONE ITEM ON. SB
TEN FROM THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE. WITH RECOMMENDED TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS IS OUR MOTION OF
THAT BILL. THEIR SECOND. IS
THERE A MOTION AND A SECOND. WE
HAD WORKED IN THE I THINK WE
HAVE TO RECALL YES YOUR HARLEY
CREEK SORRY ABOUT THAT I
THOUGHT WE HAD A CORE. Q. HERE
DEEP GABRIEL YEAH GLORIA KILEY
LEE MON BONTA QUIRK SILVA. WE
NOW HAVE CORN WITH THAT'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE TEN
ITEM I THINK THIS QUIRK SILVA
MADE A MOTION AND OUR VICE
CHAIR SECONDED. MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON CONSENT JILL HI. DEEP
GABRIEL. HI GLORIA KILEY. WE
MOAN. BONTA QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK
SILVA I. RATES ONE WE GO TO THE
FIRST ITEM AND FOLLOW ORDER AND
THAT IS FILE AND ONE AS SB NINE
DRAWS A. UNLESS YES WORK
SOMETHING OUT NOW. PLEASE.
PLEASE PROCEED OKAY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON THE COMMITTEE STAFF-
FOR THE TIME ALL THE TIME
THAT'S BEEN GIVEN- ON TO SB
NINE- THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR OUR COMMUNITY FOR OVER A
YEAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOT TO BE
YOU AND I HAVE ENGAGE WITH
RESIDENTS RENTING RENT
APARTMENTS AND HOMES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION. WITHIN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD CALLED ALSO DENTAL.
THEN THIS IS THE STATE ROUTE
SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR. MY STAFF
AND I HAVE GONE DOOR TO DOOR TO
HEAR THE CONCERNS WE'VE TALKED
TO HUNDREDS OF RESIDENTS. LAST
YEAR SINCE LAST YEAR WE HAVE
ENGAGED ALSO WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND CAL TRANS
TO URGE FAIR TREATMENT OF THESE
TENANTS AND EXPEDITE THE SALE
OF THESE PROPERTIES AT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RATES.
INCLUDING CURRENT TENANT
OCCUPIED AND VACANT PROPERTIES
AND LOTS. SB NINE WILL ALLOW
FOR THE SALE OF CALTRANS
PROPERTIES TO QUALIFIED HOUSING
RELATED ENTITIES SUCH AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
NONPROFIT HOUSING EIGHT EIGHT
ENTITIES. AT THE AGENCIES
ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE. IN
EXCHANGE FOR A GUARANTEE OF
PROVIDING FIFTY FIVE YEARS OF
AFFORDABLE AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING THAT'S THE RULE THAT WE
WERE ASKING TO BE CHANGED. SB
NINE ALLOWS AN H. R. E. TO BUY
THE PROPERTY AT THE ORIGINAL
PRICE IN EXCHANGE FOR FIXING
THEM UP AND KEEPING THEM
AFFORDABLE. SEVENTY YEARS AGO
THROUGH EMINENT DOMAIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEGAN
DISPLACING FAMILIES AND ALTERED
THE COMMUNITY OF EL SAID ANIL
FOR A PROPOSED FREEWAY
EXPANSION. CALTRANS BOUGHT
PROPERTIES. HUNDREDS OF
PROPERTIES WITHOUT REGARD FOR
THE FAMILIES IN THE QUARTER
DISRUPTED THE ECONOMIC SOCIAL
AND CULTURAL FABRIC OF THIS
PREDOMINANTLY LATINO COMMUNITY.
THEN IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY THE LEGISLATURE DECLARED
THERE WOULD BE NO EXTENSION FOR
INTERSTATE SEVEN TEN. AS THE
FUTURE OF SEVEN TEN HAS BEEN
DECIDED L. SO DENTAL HAS AGAIN
BEEN ACUTELY IMPACTED. BY MANY
MANY PROBLEMS WITH OVER ONE
HUNDRED HOMES CURRENTLY VACANT
NEARLY HALF THE CALTRANS HOMES
ARE IN EL SAID ANIL IN MANY IN
POOR CONDITION WE NOW HAVE A
NEW OPPORTUNITY. TO REPAIR AND
IMPROVE THE HOUSING IN THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD AND AT THE SAME
TIME INCREASE LONG TERM
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- NOT. ONLY
FOR LOS ANGELES BUT FOR THE
STATE. THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX RESIDENTIAL RENTERS
AND THIS ALL IN THIS PORTION OF
THE QUARTER. NOT ONLY IS THIS
IMPORTANT FOR THE COMMUNITY
IT'S ALSO FISCALLY PRUDENT
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW CALTRANS IS
REQUIRED TO FIX THE HOMES IN
ORDER TO SELL THEM. SINCE MOST
OF THESE HOMES WOULD NOT
QUALIFY FOR HABITABILITY
STANDARDS WE WANT TO PROVIDE
REPAIR THESE HOMES MAKE THEM
RESPECTABLE DIGNIFIED LIVING
SPACES WHILE EXPANDING LONG
TERM AFFORDABILITY. MY BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE THE RULES OR
GIVE ANY SPECIAL TREATMENT TO
PEOPLE WHO MAKE. 121% ABOVE THE
COUNTY MEDIAN INCOME. AND THERE
IS AN ESTABLISHED ORDER
PRIORITY TO SELL THESE
PROPERTIES THAT IS NOT CHANGING.
CALTRANS CURRENTLY HAS
APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY FIVE
TENANTS IN THIS QUARTER
PARTICIPATING IN AN AFFORDABLE
RENT PROGRAM. HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY IS A TOP PRIORITY
FOR US THIS YEAR AND EVERY YEAR
UNTIL WE AND THE CRISIS IT IS
CRITICAL WE PURSUE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESERVE AND
EXPAND AFFORDABLE OPTIONS. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO MOBILE OWNERSHIP
AWAY FROM CALTRANS SECURE LONG
TERM AFFORDABILITY AND INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE UNITS
WHILE MAKING SURE THAT CURRENT
TO CALTRANS TENANTS ARE
PROTECTED BY RULES ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. RESIDENTS
RENTING APARTMENTS AND HOMES
DESERVE FAIR TREATMENT AND TO
BE STABLE. THEY WILL NOW HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY IT'S BEEN NINE
IT'S GOING TO PROVIDE THAT LONG
TERM SOLUTION FOCUSING ON THE
PRIMARY GOAL. EXPANDING AND
PRESERVING AFFORDABILITY FOR
THESE PROPERTIES FOR PROTECTING
THE RIGHTS OF TENANTS.
COLLEAGUES TODAY WE HAVETWO
EXPERTS ON THE PHONE NONPROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPER BE A THREE
STOPS HER FROM NEW ECONOMICS
FOR WOMEN AS WELL AS JENNY
SCANLON CHIEF DEVELOPMENT
OFFICER WITH THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HOUSING AUTHORITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN WE
HEAR FROM YOUR FIRST WITNESS-
IF I GET US MODERATOR TO PLEASE
ALLOW JENNY SCANLON. TO TESTIFY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISS
CAROLINE CARE THIS IS DENNY
HAMLIN CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. THANK YOU GET A SCAM AND
YOU DEVELOPMENT OFFICER WITH
THE HOUSING AUTHORITY- I'D LIKE
TO SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE
TODAY- EVEN BEFORE THE CURVE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC REACHED. LA
COUNTY WE HAD MORE THAN SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND OF OUR RESIDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
ALMOST SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND LOW
INCOME PEOPLE WERE SPENDING 90%
OF THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING. THE
CITY OF LA FRANK NEAR THE TOP
OF THE LIST. OF PLACES WHERE
RENTERS EXPERIENCE THE HIGHEST
COST BURDEN. AT OUR HOUSING
AUTHORITY WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS
WAITING ON OUR PUBLIC HOUSING
WEIGHTLESS. AND WE OPEN UP OUR
APPLICATION. IT RECEIVED OVER
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS. ABOUT TWO YEARS
AGO PROTECTION A WEIGHTLESS. WE
ALSO NOW THERE'S AN EVEN
GREATER POPULATION IN LA. EIGHT
FACING POTENTIAL AND HANDING IT
ACTION IS NEEDED JOB LOSSES IN
AN INABILITY TO KEEP UP WITH
THEIR ALREADY HIGH RAMPART AND-
WE BELIEVE THAT SENATOR ROBB
THE BILL IS WELL TIMED WITH A
CRISIS. THERE'S NO BETTER TIME
TO ACT IF THE BOOK BY THE PATH.
AND THE APPROACH FOR ALLOWING
THE STATE ASSET. BE UTILIZED.
IMMEDIATELY NEED LOCAL
AFFORDABLE MADE. AND TO
ADDRESS. THE BLIGHT THAT THEY
CREATE. THIS IS A HISTORIC
OPPORTUNITY WHICH GIVE
EVERYBODY RIGHT I THINK THE
THING TENANTS INTACT. AND
ALLOWS FOR NATURAL MIX
AFFORDABLE OWNERSHIP AND RENTAL
HOUSING. WE THINK THAT THE
CLARITY AND APPROACH PRICE
POINT ALLOWS THAT'S NOT THE
BURDEN. OTHER COMPETITORS STATE
AND LOCAL RESOURCES TARGETED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING- TO
ACQUIRE IN REHAB THE SITE. IT
PROVIDES THAT THE BAND WITH AND
FINANCIAL OPPORTUNITY UTILIZED
PROSTRATING. INVEST IN EXCESS
READ WILLING UNITS ON THE FIGHT.
OR MAKING NEEDED REPAIRS AND
MAXIMIZING OPPORTUNITY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- AND
EXPANDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
THE LA MARKET. OUR HOUSING
AUTHORITY WITH THE GREATEST
THIS INTO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
SENATOR TORONTO AND THE
WONDERFUL FABRIC CALTRANS HAVE
RECENTLY ENTERED INTO A MASTER
LEAD TO USE THEM IN A SECOND
HOMES AS TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
WE'RE WORKING WELL TOGETHER BUT
THE PROPERTY TO GET YOU. TO THE
PEOPLE OF LA AND OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW ANDTHIS BILL WILL
ALLOW IT TO BUILD ON THESE
EFFORTS AND IT'S NOT HORRIBLY
TYPE. HOW THE MARKET. I AM
HAPPY TO. BE A PRIMARY WITNESS
BUT IT'S STILL- AND TO SHARE
ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION THAT
WE CAN HELP. YOU MAKE A
DECISION TO HOPEFULLY APPROVE
THIS. AND LET THIS TOWARD.
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE TO THE
WITNESS NUMBER TWO- TO THE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ALLOW BEATRICE START SIR TO
TESTIFY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IS
SUCH AN HONOR TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY- MY NAME IS THE STOP
THERE ON THE BOARD MEMBER OF
NEW ECONOMIC FOR WOMEN. WHO
CURRENTLY- WHAT. NOBODY AT.
HELLO AND THEIR FAMILIES NEED
WITH NOTRE FOR OUR NOT ONLY
BEING THE ONLY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATION
OPERATED BY LATINO BUT HAVE
BEEN RECOGNIZED- BY MANY-
ENTITIES THAT PROVIDE UNIQUE-
DESIGN AND HOUSE BEING THAT
MEET THE NEEDS OF LARGE
FAMILIES WE HAVE DONE AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF WORK-
AROUND A PORTABLE HOUSING. AND
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY MANY
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
RESULTED IN OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
MANTECH FAMILY HOUSING. ANALYST
CURRENTLY ONE OF THE ONLY
NONPROFIT THE NATURE EACH
BUILDING WE HAVE BEEN AND HOW
YOU THINK ABOUT THE HOME WE
HAVE A HUNDRED THIRTEEN DATE
WHICH DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
CURRENT- SECOND PROPERTY HOW-
FROM CALTRANS THEY WE WERE
SUCCESSFULLY. ABLE TO BET ON AN
AWARD IT- WE HAVE ALSO KNOWN
FOR BUILDING COMMERCIAL. PUBLIC
SCHOOL CAN HELP BASS IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITY. WE THANK YOU
TODAY FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE. THIS
BILL A LEMONADE THE CURRENT
CONDITIONS AND RESTRICTIONS
COVENANTS WITH LOCATED WHERE.
CALTRANS AFFORDABLE SALES. THAT
ARE VERY- TO THE OPPOSITION AND
WE HAVE OF THESE PARCELS ALONG
WHAT IS KNOWN AS THE STATE
ROAD. SEVEN TEN CORD. FOR
EXAMPLE. SB ELIMINATE BE A
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK AND THE
DEED RESTRICTIONS. THAT WOULD
MAKE IT ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR
ANY DEVELOPER WHETHER PROFIT OR
NONPROFIT TO ORIGINATE
COMMERCIAL LOAN CURED BY THESE
PROPERTIES. ARE YOU ABLE TO I
THANK THANK YOU SB WHAT A THE
DIRECT SALE OF THE PROPERTY
TURN HR EITHER REPRESENTS ANENORMOUS OPPORTUNITY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RICHARD
ALREADY CAUGHT. EFFORT ARE YOU.
OKAY IF I COULD ASK. IF
EVERYONE COULD PLEASE ANOTHER
DAY. IF YOU COULD HAVE ON THE
CALL COULD PLEASE ME YOURSELF
EXCEPT FOR THE SPEAKER ALL.
THANK YOU THANK. YAKKING IT LET
ME TOUCH WITH A LOCAL OF WHAT I
THINK THAT. I TRY TO. LOOK AT
HER EIGHT MORE FOR EXAMPLE
SUBORDINATING TO A LENDER IS
VERY YOUNG. AND THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE BEEN AN EXTRAORDINARY BEAR
YOUR REGARDLESS OF WHO IS THE
DEVELOPER TO BE ABLE TO GET
ACQUISITION- BRIDGE GAPS WE
HAVE A PERMANENT FINANCING
FEATURED BY THE PROPERTY. IT
ALSO WOULD ALLOW THE DIRECT OF
THE PROPERTY TO THE NATURE
READING WHICH REPRESENT AN
ENORMOUS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT THE
CURRENT HOUSING CRISIS IN A
VERY CONCENTRATED EFFORT. AND
IN A COMMUNITY THAT DESPERATELY
NEEDS THAT. BIG UNITS ARE WOULD
BE LOCKED TO MARKET RATE
PURCHASER SHOULD IT NOT BE DONE
THAT WAY- IT WILL ALSO ALLOW
PORTABILITY. CHANGE ON THE
SUPPORT. AND I KNOW WHAT A
LABEL THE LONG PRESIDENT OF THE
PROPERTY TO REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES AND IN THE COMMUNITY.
WHICH I BELIEVE IT'S ALL OF OUR-
WE THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO YOU REGARDING
THE SUPPORT OF THAT THE NINE AT
WE BELIEVE THAT WOULD REALLY
ALLOW FOR ABOUT MODERN. IF YOU
HAVE BEEN LIVING IN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE NOW ASK
IF THERE ARE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT SUPPORT THIS BILL. COULD
PLEASE ALLOW THE MODERATOR TO
OPEN LINE FOR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TESTIMONY AND FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS IF YOU COULDPLEASE. TELL US YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT THAT
YOU SUPPORT. TO THE MONITOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NUMBER
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE NOW. IN ONE MOMENT
DETERMINE. THIS IS FOR THERE'S
NO- MOTION FOR THIS YEAR CAN I
MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE IF WE
NINE THERE'S PROMOTION IS OUR
SECOND. TECH. OKAY WE DO HAVE
ONE TWO ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. I'M
BROWSING IN HUMAN RIGHT
EVERYONE DESERVES HOUSING THEY
CAN AFFORD IN YET WERE LIVING
IN ONE OF THE MOST HIS NUMBER
HIS NAME OUT. IF YOU COULD
PLEASE FOR THIS PORTION OF THE
TESTIMONY JUST TELL US YOUR
NAME. WHAT ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING AND JUST SAY YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL. YOU FOR THOSE
INSTRUCTIONS I WOULD NOT GIVEN
THEM I DO NOT SUPPORT THE BILL
I'M ATTENDING. THAT DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THIS BILL AND I
WOULD REQUIRE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GET OUT ITS MISSION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE
THERE OTHER MEMBERS OF THAT
SUPPORT THE BILL. TO THE
MODERATE TO ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
NUMBER NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T THEY'RE ALL THAT IN
SUPPORT OF SB NUMBER NINE LINE
NUMBER TWO ONE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ENTERING AMPLY. I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI- WAS VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. WE
THANK SENATOR DRAWS ALL
REPRESENTING THIS MEASURE TODAY
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE BEHIND
THE SCENES WITH CALTRANS TO
COME WITH THE RESOLUTION SO
WE'RE CALL SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT MINUTES. LINE
ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS ANASTASIA YOGA UP LIVE-
A MEMBER OF SAN FRANCISCO
TENANTS UNION I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN ORDER TO ROUTE
THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TO
THE MOUNTAIN TIME TO SHERMAN WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN IN Q. OKAY
LET'S NOW GO TO THE OPPOSITION
THERE ARE NO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES LET'S GO TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC- WHO MAY WASH TO
OPPOSE THIS. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NUMBER NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIDN'T ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
NUMBER NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE
MOMENT. IN LINE TWO ZERO FIVE
YOUR LINE OF THE PLEASE GO. I'M
REALLY CARILLO AND I AM
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
TENANTS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THIS BILL
AND AT THE COR MEETING MEMBER
OF UNITED CALTRANS TENANTS WE
IMPLORE YOU PROPOSE THAT WE
NINE AS IT IS AND IF IT IS NOT
MODIFIED. BUT IF THE SENATORS
WITH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE
THERE OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT OPPOSE THE BILL. I TWO
ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO ZERO
SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS ROBERT THE FLORA AYE OPPOSED
THE BILL I'M A MEMBER OF THE
NIGHT CALTRANS DAN AND I THINK
IT IS EXPLICIT LY- IT IT DOES
IT ATTACKS SO IT DIVIDE THAT
pCOMMITTEE IT TAKES AWAY THE
RIGHTS OF MIDDLE INCOME FOLKS
TO PURCHASER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC OPPOSE THE BILL. I
NUMBER NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ANGELO
FLOATED I AM A TENANT. AND
SOUTH PASADENA AND I BELONG TO
THE UNITED CALTRANS TENANTS FOR.
I DON'T REMEMBER MY THE OTHER
ABOUT SO REACHING OUT TO ME OR
ANY OF THE PEOPLE ON MEMBERS OF
YOUR FEET HE AND TALKING TO US
AND WE DO NOT SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT THE
TIME OF THE TERM AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU GREAT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS TO THE AUTHOR. I WILL
JUST SAY I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR WORKING ON THIS I
KNOW THIS IS A LONG STANDING
ISSUE. OF HOW WE- FIGURE OUT A
GOOD PROCESS TO. ALLOW FOR THE
SALE OF THESE CALTRANS
PROPERTIES. TO FORMER OCCUPANTS
AT. AT FOUR WILL PRICES. AND TO
ORDER AND YOU HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS TO MAINTAIN THE
AFFORDABILITY THE PROPERTIES.
WITH THAT I SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL FORWARD. AND LESSER FINAL
COMMENTS THIRTY BEEN A MOTION
SECOND CENTER ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. VERY FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND- WE HOPE TO DO GOOD FOR ALL
THOSE MANY HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES
THAT REALLY DESERVE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SHE'LL. SHE'LL I
DEEP. DEEP I GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GLORIA GLORIA AYE AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE WE MOAN BONTA QUIRK
SILVA. QUIRK SILVA HI HI YOUR
BILL HAS NO SPORTS BEFORE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL WAIT FOR AT
ON MEMBERS. LET'S BRING UPS
WELL YES TO ITEMS IN FRONT OF
US FILE ITEMS TWO AND THREE ALL
LASTLY STARTS WITH FILE ITEM TO.
WHICH IS SB. SEVEN NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THIS IS SB
SEVEN NINETY FIVE THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INVESTMENT
PROGRAM AND I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THANKING YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THE WORK ON THE BILL THIS BILL
HAS BEEN RESTRUCTURED. TO
MEETING THE RESPOND TO PREVENT
NINETEEN. THE BILL MAKES
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS TO
ADDRESS OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS WELL ALSO STIMULATE OUR
ECONOMY GENERATING HIGH WAGE
JOBS. WITH COBRA NINETEEN
RESURGING IN OUR STATE THE BILL
IS NEEDED NOW MORE THAN EVER.
FOCUSING ON HOUSING PRODUCTION.
ASSIST IN OUR PROGRAM NINETEEN
RECOVERY BY CREATING MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. FOR POOREST
FAMILIES TO SHELTER IN PLACE
SAFELY WELL GENERALLY HIGHWAYS
CONSTRUCTION JOBS TO HELP
OFFSET THE HARD AND
UNEMPLOYMENT THE BILL INVEST
TWO BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FOR FIVE YEARS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS. AND PROGRAMS
THAT ADDRESS AND PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS. ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL CREATES TO PROGRAMS. WITH
MISTER TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THEIR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AND NATURAL DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS. ACCORDING TO-
HOUSING COMMITTEE DEVELOP
DEPARTMENT HOUSING PRODUCTION
PROGRAMS AND CALIFORNIANS ARE
ALMOST ENTIRELY FUNDED WITH
BOND REVENUE AND THEIR LIMITED
FUNDS REMAINING WE'RE VERY
PROUD TO PASS PROPOSITION ONE
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND THAT
MONEY WILL BE DEPLETED REALLY
SHORTLY IN A MATTER A COUPLE
YEARS. AS A MEMBER OF THE
WORKING GROUP DEVELOPING- OUR
BICAMERAL PROPOSAL FOR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY I FEEL PASSIONATE THE
HOUSING MUST BE A CENTRAL PIECE.
OF THE PLAN. BUT THE PRO TEM OF
THE SPEAKER AGREE THAT OUR
STATE- WILL NEED AN ECONOMIC
RECOVERY PLAN. SO SBSEVEN
NINETY FIVE PROVIDES THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE STRATEGIC
INVESTMENT. THAT ADDRESSED OUR
HOUSING CRISIS THERE'S ONLY
BEEN EXASPERATED BY THE
CORVETTE NINETEEN. WITHOUT A
NEW YOUR NEW MULTI YEAR FUNDING
HOUSING PRODUCTION. WILL
DRAMATICALLY SO SLOW. AND
FORCED MORE AND MORE FAMILIES
INTO THE STREETS. I THINK
THERE'S NO DOUBT. WHERE'S THE
PROBLEM WITH TENNESSEE
EVICTIONS THE ECONOMIC CRISIS.
THAT WE'RE ALL ON PROBABILITY
GONNA HAVE AN INCREASING NUMBER
HOMELESSNESS UNLESS WE DO
SOMETHING AN AFFIRMATIVE WAY. I
URGE I WROTE ON THIS I HAVE
LIKE TO TURN OF MY WOULD JUST
MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND WITH
LEAGUE OF CITIES JASON RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO THE
MODERATOR OF WE COULD PLEASE
ALLOW JASON RYAN FROM THE
CITIES TO TESTIFY. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN CARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF MISTER CHAIR MEMBER STATION
RYAN LEE CALIFORNIA CITIES I'D
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE CENTER
ALL THIS HARD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE WE WORK TOGETHER FOR A
COUPLE YEARS HONESTY- SEVEN SB
FIVE WESTERN SEVENTY FIVE THIS
YEAR- THIS MEASURE IT IS MUCH
DIFFERENT BUT AND MY EQUALLY
IMPORTANT WE NEED TO REALLY
AMPLE. VESTMENTS PARTNER WITH
THE STATE ON EVEN THAT HOUSE
AND I'M ONLY FOR THE LEADERS
ANY CLOSE WATER SEVEN EIGHT
THIRTY TO REPRESENT WE WANT TO
SEE MORE HOW BILLS AND THAT
PARTNERSHIP THE STATE THE
FINANCE OF THE STATE. IN THE
QUEUE A TV UNITS. IN WE REALLY
THE ADDED PRO HERE OVER THE GO
I'M HERE TO HELP WITH ECONOMIC
RECOVERY IT'LL IN BUILD OFF OF
THAT HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
STIMULUS. I WAS RELEASED THIS
BOB HOPE FIRST A NAP UNDER THE.
A VERY POOR THING ARE NOT ONLY
GOOD TAKE CARE OF. AND MAKE
SURE. HOW BUT ALSO PREPARE FOR
THE NEXT DISASTER AND WHAT
THAT'S- WE GRAY APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT IN ONE OF FOUR TO. A
LOOK KIND OF SUPPORT MEASURE.
THANK YOU LET ME NOW AS THEM OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WHICH TO TEST.
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AGAIN. IF
YOU COULD PLEASE TELL US YOUR-
YOUR- AND- THE THAT YOU SUPPORT.
TO THE MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO BUT AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. IN ONE MOMENT
DETERMINE. LINE TWO TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KIDNEY AND ON BEHALF
OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
ONE ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS GREG HUNTER ON BEHALF
OF SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC NORTH
AMERICA PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB
SEVEN NINETY FIVE. NINE SEVENTY
SIX ONE OF THE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS MARK THANKS TO MAKE
THEM HAPPEN THAT CLARA VALLEY
OKAY ALREADY WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ENTER
IMMENSELY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES BEVERLY HILLS IN
SANTA MONICA ALL IN SUPPORT.
LINE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AT
LEAST YOU HAVE IT ALL ON BEHALF
OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINETY FIVE.
ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU IN LINE
TO SYSTEM MY NUMBER ONE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THIS IS JILL STEWART
REPRESENTING LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
WELL VERY VERY MUCH FOR THIS
STILL ONLY ONE I THINK SENATOR
BILL FRIST STICKING WITH IT AND
PUTTING MONEY INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BADLY BADLY NEEDED
THANK YOU. IN ONE MOMENT
DETERMINE PEOPLE ARE STILL
KILLING UP ONE MOMENT THERE.
YEAH. WE'RE STILL HOLDING THE
TERM A MOMENT. MY NUMBER TWO
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE TWO THREE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT ANY
UNDERSTAND ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE WOMAN
TURNING IN LINE TO THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TWO THREE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI BUT THE
LEGACY OF CLAIMS ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AT THE TIME
OF THE GERMAN WE HAVE NO NO
THANK YOU. TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE- ONE WITNESS
TESTIFYING IT'S KIM STONE FROM
THE ASSOCIATED. AND
CONTRACTORS- TO THE MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE ALARMIST ON
TO TESTIFY. YEAH I WANTED TO
WRITE. A GREAT HI THIS IS KIM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS CONTRACTORS BUT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AFTER. ALL
WE WERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL-
AFTER IT WAS INTERVIEWEDAND
GOING THROUGH THE PROCESS
BECAUSE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THE CONCEPT BEHIND THE BILL
AND- APPLIED TO THE OFFICE- AND
THE STATE FOR ENCOURAGING THIS
KIND OF DEVELOPMENT BUT- THE
AMENDMENT OF. EIGHTEEN
CURRENTLY EXCLUDE ARE WERE AT
OF. STUDENTS WHO ATTEND OUR PRE
APPRENTICE. AND I PRINT
PROGRAMS FROM ABLE TO ACCESS
THE BENEFITS OF THIS BILL. OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES AND ARE KIND
OF SHIPS DO NOT WANT TO BE
EXCLUDED FROM PROVIDING MUCH
NEEDED LOW INCOME HOUSING AND
WE WANT OUR FRIENDSHIP AND OUR
PENSION PROGRAMS TO GROW HELP
TO DEVELOP OUR CONSTRUCTION
WORK FORCE. THAT MONEY
ALLOCATED FOR THAT CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD-
FOR DISTRIBUTION TO LOCAL
AGENCIES ONLY ALLOWS-
BENEFICIARIES WHO USE ONE
PARTICULAR CURRICULUM CALL THEM
OKAY CRAFT COURT GIVEN. OUR
HOPE. YOU A DIFFERENT
LEGITIMATE CURRICULUM CALLED
THE NATIONAL- PRODUCED BY THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR
CONSTRUCTION EDUCATION AND
RESEARCH. OTHER GROUPS THAT
HAVE USED THEIR CURRICULUM
INCLUDED THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SYSTEM THE
CSU SYSTEM- UNTIL RECENTLY- THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND- THE COP IT
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
AUTHORIZED. OVER A HUNDRED
PEOPLE THEN YOU'D EXPECT. TO
USE THAT CORRECT I'M- IF THE
DATA COVER WE HAVE EIGHT FORTY
UP WORKER. IN THE STATE AND IN
AIDING CONSTRUCTION WORK FOR
AND SO WE WOULD URGE THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE TO REMOVE THE
LIMITATION BUT ONLY ONE
CURRICULUM AND AT STUDENT I
CAN'T USE THAT ONE CREEK COULD
RECEIVE THE- THERE ARE. WE
PERFECTLY OPPOSE THE BELL AND
THEY IS A MAN. TO INCLUDE. THE
ABSTRACT AT THE PEOPLE PRO.
THAT WE AND OTHER GROUPS
PROVIDE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER ON OUR TO THE MODERATOR
IF YOU PLEASE ALLOW OTHER MEN
THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO X.
THEIR OPPOSITION THE BILL. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN NINE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB. SEVEN NINE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THEIR OWN NOW.
IN OUR FIRST LINE IS OPEN. TO
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY APOLOGIES
IS ACTUALLY CORRECT THE PORT AT
THE POINT OF SEVENTY FIVE AS AN
AFRICAN BALLOTS ON BEHALF F
SAN JOSE MAYOR SAM LICCARDO.
AND WE THINK ABOUT FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. IN ONE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS SO IT'S A MATTER THAT
LIKE HOLD PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA WE
ACTUALLY THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION. OF CONCERN THAT THE
BILL COULD POTENTIALLY RATE
OVERALL CONSTRUCTION POP. THANK
YOU. IN LINE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN DANNY CURTAIN
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS I'M ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I JUST
COULDN'T FIGURE OUT THE PROCESS
AT THE TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND YOUR BELL- WE BELIEVE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SHOULD BE
PAID ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO LIVE
IN THAT PORTABLE HOUSING AND WE
THANK THIS. THEN WE DO HAVE
PAID THE HOUSING BILLS OUT THAT
WE MUST DO TO BE HER. BACK INTO
LAW THANK YOU MUCH. AGAIN IF
YOU WOULD SPEAK UP A- OF AND-
SEVEN FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ALL. IN LINE ONE
NINETY FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN
NINE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU DAVID WHEATLEY A LOS
ANGELES I'M CONCEPTUALLY IN
FAVOR OF THIS PROJECT BUT I'M
VERY INTERESTED TO KNOW WHAT.
TWO MILLION TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND RENTER HOUSEHOLDS THAT
NEED A HOUSING AND THESE PEOPLE
LIVING IN OUR VIS HAUSSER
PAYING HANG OUT WITH THEIR
FRIENDS ALSO VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT AND- INTO. NAY WITHIN
FELT. AND I THINK THIS MEANS
HAVE SOME LIMITATIONS ON IT
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PROBABLY NOT HAPPEN AND
THE REGION OPEN DISTRICTS WE
ARE ACTUALLY SUPPORT OF THE
BILL LIKE CAN I GET THROUGH THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE WERE GONNA
RECORD FOR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE TWO FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE TWO
FORTY ONE. ONE TWO FORTY ONE
REMINDED OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I TO FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE TWO
FOUR FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS RICHARD MARX AND ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION ECHOING THE
OPPOSITION OF MISS STONE- TO
THE DISCRIMINATORY PROVISIONS
OF THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER TWO FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN LINE TWO FOUR
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I
LIVE IN A HISTORIC NEIGHBORHOOD
IN LOS ANGELES AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT THIS- SO I. THIS
NOT BE AYE AYE DEATH WANT TO
CITY AND STATE TO FIND SOLUTION
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING THIS
SEEMS LIKE A- BALLOON FOR
DEVELOPERS. WE HAVE A LOT OF
VACANT- CONDOMINIUM IN
HOLLYWOOD THAT ARE UNAFFORDABLE
FOR THE HOMELESS PEOPLE. WHO
ARE LITERALLY LIVING ON THE
STREETS BELOW THESE EXPENSIVE
CONDOMINIUMS AND WE SEE NO
REASON WHY THE HISTORIC
NEIGHBORHOOD OF US CENSUS CORPS
FOR INSTANCE SHOULD BE.
DEMOLISHED SO THE CONDOS CAN BE
BUILT THAT DOESN'T I HAVE NO
ASSURANCE THAT THE HOMELESS
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO FOR TO LIVE.
AT AND ALSO. I CAN EXPECT. ONE
MOMENT THE GERMAN THEIR QUEUE
NOT NOW. WE'LL GATHER IN THEIR
NUMBER NUMBER ONE MOMENT. THE
SECOND OF THE CHAIRMAN. MY
NUMBER TWO OR THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO THE ROTARY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS ROBIN ROUTED SO
LOS ANGELES I'M A CO FLAT THE
GET A MEMBER OF CITIZENS CLOSER
IN VENICE I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THAT SUPPORTS ADDITIONAL
HOUSING AND FUNDS TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES DEALING WITH THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
THANK YOU. IN AT THE TIME OF
THE GERMAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY DISCUSSION COLLEAGUES. A
CENTER WHY DID YOU AMEND THE
BELL TO EXCLUDE OTHER STATE AND
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
CURRICULUMS. OF GROUPS OF REYES
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROVISION
THAT PROVIDES FUNDING FOR OUR
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS-
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL PROVIDES-
A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY IF YOU
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR- FOR
FIVE YEARS. OVER A PERIOD OF
TIME FOR THE CALIFORNIA BURKE.
FORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD WHICH
FOLLOWS THE MULTI CRAFT
CURRICULUM THAT'S THE REASON.
WORKFORCE ONE BOARD- HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN- WORKING WITH THE
MULTI CRAFT CURRICULUM- TO-
INCREASE APPRENTICESHIPS YEAH
AND- MANY AREAS WHEN WE- WE
FIRST DID THIS WITH- AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH- SP ONE. WE PUT-
IT WAS FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR INTO THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S TO YOU KNOW
WE NEED MORE WORKERS FOR- THESE
PROJECTS SO. THIS IS A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
CURRICULUM AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS AND ITS USE BY THE
STATE AND FEDERALLY APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
CONSISTENT WITH SB WINE IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE BURKE
LEGISLATION. AND THAT'S THE
REASON. OKAY I'M NOT SURE I GOT
AN ANSWER THE WHY DO YOU WHY
NOT INCLUDE THESE OTHER
CURRICULUM THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED BY SOME OF THE FOLKS
WHO TESTIFIED. IN IRAQ
RECOGNIZED NATIONALLY AND STATE
YOU THINK THEY'RE NOT AS GOOD
OR JUST LIKE THE MULTI CRAFT
BETTER- I LEAVE IT TO THE
EXPERIENCE PEOPLE IN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
BOARD TO SELECT THE CORRECT ONE.
AND THEY HAVE SELECTED THE-
WHICH IS TO- EXCEPT AND OPERATE
UNDER AND THAT'S THE REASON.
MISTER GORE MISSION I JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS LEGISLATION I RECOGNIZE
YOU'VE BEEN ATTEMPTING TO WORK
ON A FUNDING SOURCE TO
FACILITATE HOUSING GROWTH-
APPRECIATE PERSISTENCE THAN A
PARTICLE AUTHORED THIS MEASURE
IT AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS ONCE THE
CONTENT. FROM THIS INVESTMENT I
STATE PAIRS. IT MEANS YOU HAVE
A SPOT TO MOVE THE ITEM.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
ANY OTHER COMMENTS. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR I KNOW THIS IS
TO THE FORMER CHAIR OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE THIS IS YOUR-
LAST TIME THIS COMMITTEE I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU'VE
DONE OVER THE YEARS FOR HOUSING
LIKE. IF PENNER CHAMPION VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE- FUNDING BILL
FOR WHAT. AND FOR HOME I KNOW
HAVE. BEEN WELL AND APPRECIATE
OUR WORK ON SB THREE- THIS IS A
COMMITTEE FOR US TO THE SIDE
DOES THIS POLICY MAKES SENSE AS
FAR AS HOUSING AND MOVING FOR
HOUSING GEN AND I THINK IT UP.
AND OBVIOUSLY THE SCHOOLS GOING
TO GO AND APPROPRIATIONS AND I
WISH YOU. CONNECT POSITION BUT
OF. WITH REPORTERS WARNS TODAY.
ANALYSTS ARE ANY FINAL COMMENTS
FROM CALL TO THE SENATE. YEAH I
THINK THE STATE THE COMMITTEES
WORK ON HOUSING ESPECIALLY
OTHER CHAIRS WORK ON-
PARTNERING WITH ME AND OTHER
SENATORS AS A TEAM OR A TEAM
TRYING TO I THINK THERE IS
CONCERN IS. IN THE LEGISLATION
WE NEED AN ONGOING SOURCE OF
FUNDING. FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- THE CHAIR HAS DONE THE
TAX CREDIT LEGISLATION AND
OTHERS AND I WORKED ON THE
PROPOSITION ONE CENTER ATKINS
WORKED ON A- FEE FOR- OF. THE
SB THREE AND- IT WE NEED TO
HAVE THE ONGOING SOURCE OF
FUNDING. RATHER THAN THIS ONE
HI. KIND OF THING THAT. HELLO
HELLO. WITH I THINK WE CAN GET
OVER THE TOP THIS YEAR WITH THE
CRISIS THERE WERE IN TO
CONVINCE THE GOVERNOR THE NEEDS
TO ADDRESSTHE ISSUE OF ONGOING
SOURCES OF FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- IT LIST DO
THIS IT'S JUST GONNA MAKE A LOT
OF THE OTHER PROBLEMS. IN OUR
WORK. BUT ON THIS MEASURE.
TORONTO LETS SO WORK ON ARE
RECOVERY AND- LET'S TRY TO MAKE
THIS WORK THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PATH AS IT DID TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS ISSUE I'VE
CHILL IT. DEEP I GAVE. APRIL
AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE AYE
KILEY. KILEY NO. LIMON I BONTA.
BONTA AYE SILVA. QUIRK SILVA I.
YOU HAVE VOTES AND WITH THAT
LET'S GO TO FILE AND THREE SB
NINE FORTY AGAIN CENTER ABOUT
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU- SB
NINE FORTY. THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL. OF WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE TO MAKE
SMART ZONING UP S THAT WILL
PROTECT OUR OPEN SPACE AND
REDUCE SPRAWL NOW IN MY
DISTRICT THE CITY OF STONE SAY
IS CURRENTLY WORKING ON AN
AGGRESSIVE PLAN TO UPDATE ITS
OWNING- YOU KNOW SOME OF THIS
IS ONLY. IT ALL GOES BACK TO
PROBABLY BEFORE ANY OF YOU WERE
BORN. MAYBE NOT ME. BUT THAT IS
ALL THE IS LIKE FIFTY SIX YEAR
OLD ZONING. THERE WAS BEFORE
GENERAL PLANS AND SO FORTH AND
THE CITY IS TRYING TO UPDATE
THEIR ZONING ESPECIALLY IN
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN SENSE THAT
ZONING FIFTY OR SIXTY YEARS AGO
WAS CREATED- IT DOESN'T. THE
GENERAL PLANS OF THE CITY FOR A
LONG TIME AS OPEN SPACE. SO
THAT'S OUR SITUATION HERE NOW
HOW DO WE DO THAT WITHIN THE
EXISTING LAWS THAT WE HAVE
ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO MY
DISTRICT SAN JOSE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE A FOCUS ON INCREASING
HOUSING PRODUCTION. SO THEY'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF REZONING THIS
ELEVEN THOUSAND ACRES OF OLD
ZONED OPEN SPACE DISTRICT
INCORRECTLY ON FOR SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES. AT THE SAME TIME
THEY'RE DOING THEIR- THERE IT
INCREASE ZONING DISTANT
DENSITY. AND URBAN CORE NEAR
THE TRANSIT LINES AND SO FORTH
BY THE BY THE AT LEAST THE A
SIMILAR AMOUNT OF YOU HOUSING
UNITS PROBABLY MORE. AND THEY
WANT TO DO THIS IN ORDER TO
COMPLY WITH OUR STATE LAWS. AND
THE CITY NEEDS AUTHORIZATION TO
GET THIS WORK DONE RIGHT AWAY
SO THAT'S WHY THE URGENCY OF
THE BILL. THE BILL AUTHORIZED
SAN JOSE TO UPS ON HOUSING
SITES PROACTIVELY. AND THEN USE
THEIR DOWNS OWN CAPACITY
PROTECT THE OPEN SPACE LAND. BY
DOWN ZONING SITE OUTSIDE URBAN
AREA. AND WE CRAP CRAFTED THIS
BILL SO THERE'D BE NO NET LOSS
IN ZONING AND NO DO YOU
DECREASE AND A HOUSING AND THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO MEET THEIR
HOUSING GOALS WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE MICHAEL BRELO. AND
MARK- LANDGRAF FROM THE OPEN
SPACES STORY I TURNED OVER TO
MY WOULD DISMISS MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU TO THE MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE. ALLOW OUR
FIRST WITNESS MARK AND GRAPH TO.
OPEN THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS HERE MISTER- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MARK LANDGRAF
WITH THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY
OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY CO SPONSOR
OF SB NINE FORTY I FIRST WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR AGENCIES
GRATITUDE TO SENATOR SKINNER
WHOSE SB THREE THIRTY SIGNED
INTO LAW LAST YEAR HELPED
ADDRESS A SEVERE HOUSING CRISIS
WE FACE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
PEOPLE SUPPORT. TIME ZONING AND
DOWN ZONING BY ALLOWING BY
ALLOWING UP ZONING FOR
INCREASED HOUSING DENSITY IN
THE URBAN CORE TO OCCUR FIRST
BE BANKED AND THEN LATER USED
FOR DOWN TUNING AND OUTLINED
AGRICULTURAL AND OPEN SPACE
AREAS. RINGS OWNING IN
CONFORMANCE WITH THE EXISTING
CHURCH AND DESIGNATION. THIS
ALLOWS YOU TO AYE AYES HOUSING.
REDUCING SPRAWL AND PROTECTING
ITS VITAL NATURAL AND WORKING
LANCE. SPRAWL NOT ONLY
DECREASED OR INCREASE. TROUBLED
AND THEREFORE HOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IT ALSO IMPACTS THE
NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE ON WHICH
RESIDENTS DEPEND TO REDUCE
FLOOD RISK DURING MAJOR STORMS
TO RECHARGE GROUNDWATER AND
JUST FOR A LOCAL REBELLION
SUPPLY. STRONG ALSO PUT MORE
HOMES IN CALIFORNIANS IN THE
WHAT THE LAND URBAN INTERFACE.
INCREASING THE EXPOSURE OF
RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITIES TO
WILDFIRE. REPORT REPORTER THE
CITY'S TO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
SPRAWL INCLUDING AN KILEY
VALLEY OPPO OF WHICH LIES
WITHIN THE CITY LIMITS OF THE
SAY AND ALL OF WHICH HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED AS A LANDSCAPE OF
WHITE IMPORTANCE BY AB NOT
FORTY. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALL
LAST YEAR AND CO AUTHORED BY
SENATOR ABOUT. WE ARE GRATEFUL
TO REBEL AND IS STAFF FOR
THEIR EFFORTS TO AUTHORED THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND
URGENT AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO THE MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO THE SECOND WITNESS
OF MICHAEL BRELO. GOOD
AFTERNOON AS CHAIR PERSON CHIU
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE M
NAME IS MICHAEL CARILLO I'M A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR IN THE CITY'S
CHANNEL STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PLANNING BUILDING AND CODE
ENFORCEMENT FORCE MEANT. FIRST
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
BELL FOR ALTERING THE SPELL I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
HOPPING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE OUR STAFF
HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL AND
LIVING THIS BILL FORWARD. IN
ADDITION A I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR SKINNER'S OFFICE
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
SCALE TO RESOLVE THE TECHNICAL
CHALLENGES CREATED BY SB THREE
THREE ZERO. VIDEO CHANNELS THEY
HAD ELEVEN THOUSAND ACRES OF
LAND DESIGNATED IN ITS GENERAL
PLAN FOR AGRICULTURAL AND OPEN
SPACE. THIS PLAN IS INTENDED TO
BE PRESERVED FOR AGRICULTURAL
USES NATIVE PLANT AND ANIMAL
SPECIES. IT'S NATIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE YOUR MAKER
COMMUNITIES MORE RESILIENT TO
CLIMATE CHANGE. THIS LAND. IS
ZONED FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
THANKS. LEGACY IT CITY MANAGER
DUTCH HAMMOND. JOURNEYS OUT
LIKE ERR WORLD. AS A STEP TO
IMPLEMENT ASIAN AND MAKING
SATURDAY. BRAWLING SUBURBANS
EIGHT. BEGINNING IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY CENTER THEY
SHIFTED TO THE SMART GROWTH
ENERGY.ESTABLISHING BUT BROWN
SHE GRAY IN ANY STILL A-
CURRENTLY THE CITY UNDERTAKE A
GRAY PLAN TO AND- TO. IN TO A
HOUSING AT CITY CENTER CLOSE TO
TRANSIT IN PART TO ADDRESS THE
CURRENT HOUSING CRISIS. AT THE
SAME IN THE CITY TAKING STEPS
TO FURTHER PRESERVE OUR
AGRICULTURE ON OPEN SPACE AREAS
OUTSIDE GOT ANGRY. INSTEAD
WATCHING INADVERTENT IN BACK OF
THE BUILDING AND AS TO PRESERVE
PEACE PLANS. SENATE BILL NINE
FORTY WILL OPERATE SCANNERS
DATA DON'T HOUSING SIX
PROACTIVELY AND HAVE UP TO A
YEAR DOWN THE SITE. DOWN SEVEN
OTHER SITES TO ENSURE NO NET
LOSS IN RESIDENTIAL HOUSE CITY.
IS SO I'M SURE THAT TENER THEY
CAN MEET THE OBLIGATIONS TO
CONSULT A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CONSISTENT WITH PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING OPEN MASON
AGRICULTURAL LANDS. I SHOULD
KNOW THAT WE HAVE MADE
AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE. TO THE
PROVISIONS THAT DEALT. UPON THE-
CAN HELLO HOW L. OF FOR THE SIX
IS DUE TO THE STATE AND THE
ATTY CAN PROVISIONS WHERE THE
CITY MOSCOW ON A WEBSITE
REPORTED EACH NINE AND THAT
WOULD BE GREAT THAT WOULD
REDUCE RESIDENTIAL CAPACITY
CENTER THEY RESPECT
RESPECTFULLY URGES YOUR-
SUPPORT SB NINE FORTY THIS YEAR
TO ALLOW THE CITY FLEXIBILITY
TO MOVE FORWARD EXPEDITIOUSLY
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE GRAD USED
CIRCLE LAND MADE THE CULTURE AT.
GENERAL THANK YOU. THANKS VERY
MUCH FROM S. C. GREATER TO
ALLOW OTHER IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TO DESCRIBE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT OF
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE FOUR ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WHICH BE AT THE PORT OF
SB NINE FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE
MOMENT DETERMINE. TOGETHER
THEIR NUMBERS. MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT TOOK ME ON
BEHALF BRIDGE HOUSING AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS JEAN HURTH CALLING
IN TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. LINE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CLUB CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE FOR THEIR OLD THAT
ONE TWO ZERO PRESS ONE TO THEIR
OWN NOW. LYING TO TWENTY TWO
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
THE AUDREY RETIRED CHECK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWO FORTY TWO THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER TWO
FORTY TWO ZERO NINE IT'LL. AT
THE TIME OF THE GERMAN THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION ARE THERE IS NO.
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY LET ME ASK
IF THERE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC THE
WHICH TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. TO
THE MODERATOR. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
FOUR ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB NINE
FOUR ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE MOMENT
THE GERMAN. MY NUMBER TWO FOUR
TWO THEIR LINE OF GOLD PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER TWO FORTY
TWO THE LINE IS OPEN. YES I CAN
HEAR YOU NOW. HI THIS IS
NATALIE KNOCKED ON BEHALF OF
THE- OPEN SPACE DISTRICT I'M A
CLAIM WORK YEAH. MY NUMBER ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE NINETY FIVE THE LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU DAVID WHEATLEY
AND LOS ANGELES- THIS IS A LOT
TO READ AS A NEWCOMER BUT I'M
OPPOSED TO ANYTHING THAT
INVOLVES THE DEMOLITION- BUT
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES ARE
ACTUALLY ANY STRUCTURES. ALSO
I'M WONDERING IF THE MODERATOR-
IN JUST BEFORE THE VOTE COULD
REFRAIN FROM A LOBBYING FOR IT
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER SO COULD
NOT AFFECT INDIVIDUAL BOATS
THAT THE FORMER JURY
INSTRUCTIONS THANK. YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU. I REMEMBER THE PART
NUMBERS TO BE FORTY. LIKE FOR
ONE LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD. LINE
NUMBER TWO FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND THE DETERMINE
THERE ARE NO ONE THERE ARE NO
ONE I THINK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD
SIR THANK YOU LET'S BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS.
THIS WAS A TO THE CENTER THANK%
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL
PARTICULARLY WITH- A YOUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR SKINNER- IN A
WE JUST PASSED SB THREE THIRTY
LAST YEAR SO. HI I HAVE TO
ADMIT WE WERE A LITTLE
SKEPTICAL OF ANYTHING THAT
WOULD AMEND THAT BILL BUT- YOUR
BILL HAS ALL THE RIGHT GUARD
RAILS INCLUDING. REQUIRED UP
SONY'S FOR DOWN ZONING IS
LIMITING APPLICABLE. DOWN
SONY'S TO THOSE ARE REQUIRED BY
STATE LAW. ANNA SHORTS. WHICH
IS WHY OF THANK YOU FOR TO THE
BILL SO SPECIFICALLY TO FURTHER
OUR STATE GOALS PROMOTE INFILL
HOUSING. AND PREVENTING SPRAWL.
AND IF THERE'S NO FOR THIS.
FREDDIE FARKAS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS A LONG TIME A
POLISH THE CITY SO AS A
pPROBABLY ABOUT- FORTY YEARS-
BECAUSE FORTY YEARS AGO I
BECAME A MEMBER OF THE SAN JOSE
CITY COUNCIL THAT WAS MY FIRST
JOB SO IT'S BEEN FORTY YEARS
FORTY YEARS NOW THIS IS MY
FORTIETH YEAR OFFICE PUBLIC
OFFICE. RIGHT WAS IN OFFICE-
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE IN THE
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES REZONE THIS
PROPERTY. SO IT WAS DECIDED BY
THE VOTERS TO CREATE AN OPEN
SPACE AREA AND NOT A LOT OF BUT
EXCUSE ME IF ANYONE IS ON THE
LINE IF YOU COULD PLEASE PUT
YOURSELVES ON MUTE THANK YOU.
YEAH AND- THIS IS NOW JUST OPEN
SPACE THERE'S NO HOUSING THERE
SO THE COMMENT MADE ABOUT
REMOVING HOUSING THERE'S NO
HOUSING THERE IT'S A OTHER THAN
BARNES AND SOME FARMHOUSES.
WHICH WILL NOT BE REMOVED- SO-
CHEN AYE VOTE ON THIS THIS
WILL. INCREASE ACTUALLY THE
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AROUND TRANSIT IN SAN JOSE- WE
THINK THIS IS GOOD LAND USE
PLANNING AND GOOD FOR HOUSING
SO WE SUPPORT THIS. THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT. IS OUR MOTION TO
MOVE THIS FOR. COLLEAGUES IS
THERE SECOND HAS BEEN MOTION A
SECOND BY MS ENORMOUS BOND
MATTER SECRETARY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS. JILL HI JILL I DEEP.
DEEP I GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA
GLORIA I KILEY KILEY AYE LIMON
LIMON AYE BONTA BONTA AYE QUIRK
SILVA. QUIRK SILVA I. THANK YOU
YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR WIENER WE HAVE
TWO ITEMS. FOR USE FILE ITEMS
FOR FIVE- ALLOW SKI IF YOU'D
LIKE TO TAKE A BUS BE.
EIGHT
NINETY NINE NINE FOUR. MA'AM
TERMS PLEASE. OUR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THANK YOU
AND THE COMMITTEE OFFER HERE IN
THIS BILL TODAY AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND STAFF
WERE RECOMMENDING- AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL- AND I RESPECTFULLY
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT
OUTLINED BY IN THE ANALYSIS. I
DO WANT TO- NOTES IN THE CHAIR
AND I HAVE DISCUSSED THIS THAT
THERE IS AN AMENDMENT WHICH I'M
ACCEPTING TODAY- THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS REQUESTED- FOCUS
ON A CHANGE TO THE DEFINITION
OF THE HISTORIC DISTRICT
EXCLUSION I AND THE BILL I DO
JUST WANT TO MENTION THAT THAT
LANGUAGE. I WAS INTENSE THE ALL
RIGHT THROUGH THE SENATE
LEADERS ARE HOUSING WORKING
GROUP THE LANGUAGE ALL APPEARS
IN OTHER. HOUSING BILLS. THE
SENATE THING PACKAGE TOTAL
PERCENT THROUGHOUT THE- I WAS
TO AFTER A LENGTHY PROCESS
UNDER THE SEA. OF THE SENATE
PRESIDENT- CENTER ATKINS AND
HER STAFF. AND OTHER CENTERS ON
THE WORKING GROUP. I SOME
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS- IN
REFERENCE TO THE COMMITTEE- AND
TO THE CHAIR- AND I KNOW THAT
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE TWO
HOUSES AMONG MANY ISSUE THE
MANY MANY ISSUES THAT HAVE TO
DISCUSS COMING WEEKS- I AM NOT
THE SCHOOL OF BROUGHT UP AS
WELL. I SAID I DO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. SO OUR
COLLEAGUES ARE SENATE BILL
EIGHT NINTY NINE- IS A PURE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BILL. I'VE
GOT HOUSING FOR. LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS- THE WORKING POOR
FORMALLY HOMELESS PEOPLE LOW
INCOME SENIORS. EMANCIPATED
FOSTER YOUTH AND SO ON AND SO
FORTH WE KNOW WE HAVE. A
PROFOUND SHORTAGE OF HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA AND PARTICULARLY A
PROFOUND SHORTAGE OF HOUSING.
THAT IS AFFORDABLE TO OUR
LOWEST INCOME. RESIDENTS ARE WE
SEE THE RESULTS OF THIS EVERY
DAY WE SEE IT WITH PEOPLE WHO
ARE DEEPLY STRUGGLING WITH OUR
HOUSING. BUT WE ALSO SEE A WITH
THE EXPLOSION. OF HOMELESSNESS
IN OUR STATE- THE INCREASING
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO ARE.
LIVING FULL TIME IN THEIR CARS.
PEOPLE WHO WERE LIVING IN
HOMELESS SHELTERS. ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE LIVING IN PARKS AND ON
OUR STREETS. CALIFORNIA
COMPRISES APPROXIMATELY
THIRTEEN PERCENT. OF THE
POPULATION OF THE UNITED
STATES. BUT COMPRISES 25% OF
THE NATION'S HOMELESS
POPULATION AND MORE THAN HALF
OF THE NATION'S. I SHELTERED
HOMELESS THIS IS A MORAL
ABOMINATION. AND WE HAVE A DUTY
TO ADDRESS IT AND THERE MANY
MANY THINGS WE NEED TO DO TO
FIX OUR HELPING TO BUCKLE. AND
ONE OF THEM IS AGGRESSIVELY
BUILDING HOUSING FOR OUR LOWEST
INCOME RESIDENTS. AND WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY WITH THIS BILL
TO MOVE THE DIAL. AND WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IN THIS BILL HAS A
HUGE. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COALITION BEHIND IT IS
SPONSORED. BY THE TWO LARGEST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COALITIONS.
AND THE STATE OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A
NONPROFIT HOUSING AND THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION AND WHAT
THE BILL WILL DO IS IT WILL
ALLOW CHURCHES AND OTHER
RELIGIOUS NONPROFITS AS WELL AS
NONPROFIT COLLEGES. TO TAKE
THEIR ACCESS LANDS AND TO TURN
IT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER IN THE HOUSING FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE DEED
RESTRICTED BELOW MARKET RATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. A RECENT
STUDY- BY THE TURNER CENTER
BERKELEY I ESTIMATED NOT EVEN
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE STATE.
LOOKING ONLY AT ALAMEDA COUNTY
LA COUNTY SACRAMENTO COUNTY SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY JUSTICE COUNTIES ALONE
HAVE TEN THOUSAND ACRES OF
DEVELOPED OVER LAND THE COULD
BE USED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND THAT'S JUST IN THOSE
COUNTIES WITH AN EXTRAORDINARY
AMOUNT OF I'M- A RIDICULOUS- WE
HAVE CHURCHES WITH THE CLIMBING
ENROLLMENT SET SO THEY HAVE
ACCESS. PARKING WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE THIS BILL PAIRS
WHAT A BILLABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WORKS BUT THE ASSEMBLY PASSED
AND SO THIS CAN REALLY HELP US
THE DIAL. THE BILL WILL ALLOW
FOR THE AND APPROVE THE BUYER
APPROVAL OF THE IS A 100%
AFFORDABLE PROJECTS THAT MEET
CERTAIN SPECIFIC CRITERIA THERE
ARE LIMITS ON HEIGHTS IT OFTEN
DIFFERS THE LOCAL HIGH LIMIT IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS ARE LOCAL
HERE A PLUS WINE AND COMMERCIAL
MIXED USE AREAS. IT HAS TO BE
IN AND BILL AREA WE'RE NOT
LOOKING TO GENERATE A SPRAWL
AND THEIR LIMITS- TO DENSITY
THERE ARE OTHER CONSTRAINTS- AS
WELL- TO TRY TO REALLY MAKE
SURE WE'RE REALLY BALLOT SAYING
THE LOCAL ASPECTS OF ROOF WITH
A DRAMATIC. IT FOR AFFORDABLE
HEALTH. THE CALL WE ARE TO
DECRY. AND THIS BILL IS PART OF
THE SO. I DO WANNA- TO A
KNOWLEDGE- DYNAMIC AROUND THIS
BILL AND THAT IS THAT I KNOW
YOU'LL HEAR THIS TODAY. THAT
THE BUILDING TRADES ARE
OPPOSING THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED- RELATING TO LABOR
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL AND I JUST
WANT TO TOUCH ON THAT. AND I
SAY THIS AS SOMEONE HO I'M NOT
A JOHNNY COME LATELY TO THE
TRADES I'VE BEEN WORKING HAND
IN GLOVE WITH THE TRADES WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES. GOING BACK
TO PROBABLY TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR TWO THOUSAND FIVE WHEN I
WAS A NEW MEMBER. OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEMOCRATIC COUNTY
CENTRAL COMMITTEE AND THEN I
BECAME CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
AND I STOOD IN SOLIDARITY WITH
THE TRADE. AS A MEMBER OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I WAS ONE OF THE
STAUNCHEST ALLIES. OF THE
TRADES AND FIGHTING FOR PLA'S.
AND FIGHTING FOR WORKING
CONDITIONS FOR OUR CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS. AND IN THE SENATE I
HAVE BEEN A STAUNCH ALLY. OF
THE TRADES ON AND LESS AND LESS
AND LESS ISSUES. I WANT ARE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. TO BE IN
THE MIDDLE CLASS. WE DON'T WANT
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS BEING PAID
POVERTY WAGES WE DON'T WANT
WAIT STAFF TO. PROMOTE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. WE WANT A
BROAD SKILLED WORKFORCE WE NEED
TO RAMP UP APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS. THERE ARE SO MANY
BENEFITS. TO HAVING A STRONG
SKILLED WORK FORCE OF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THIS BILL AND I
AM IN THE PAST AS YOU MAY
RECALL IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHEN
I AUTHORED. THIRTY THE HOUSE
STREAM. THAT WAS PASSED THAT IS
USUALLY SIX NOW. HOUSING
PROTECT FOR THE HOUSING BUT A
LOT OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
HOUSING UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
AND WE PUT SKILLED WORKFORCE
LANGUAGE AND NOT BILL FOR
MARKET RATE AND MEXICAN
HOUSING. AND WE PUT PREVAILING
WAGE AND NOT BILL FOR A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THE
BUILDING TRADES SUPPORTED THAT
BILL. AND OF THE RULE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR MANY YEARS HAS
BEEN FOR A 100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
BENEFIT. WHETHER IT'S MONEY OR
STREAMLINING YOU HAVE TO PAY
PREVAILING WAGE THIS BILL HAS
STRONG PREVAILING WAGE LANGUAGE
IN A- ARE CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
LAWS. FOR A 100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THE BUILDING TRADES
THIS YEAR HAVE REEVALUATED
THEIR POSITION AND DECIDED THAT
THEY THINK THEY BELIEVE THAT
SKILLED WORK FORCE PROTECTION
SHOULD APPLY TO A 100%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. I
COMPLETELY RESPECT THAT CHOICE
BY THE TRADES. THEY HAVE
REEVALUATED POSITION. EVERYONE
IS ENTITLED TO DO THAT LIFE IS
NOT STATIC I AM A SUPPORTER OF
SKILLED WORKFORCE PROTECTIONS
FOR WORKERS IT HELPS US TO RAMP
UP APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IT
HELPS US TO ENSURE WE'RE NOT
PAYING CONSTRUCTION WORKER.
POVERTY WAGES THAT HELPS CREATE
A PATH TO MIDDLE CLASS IT
AVOIDS WAIT STAFF THERE ARE SO
MANY BENEFITS OF IT. WE ARE AND
PRESERVATION WITH THE TRADES
ARE YOU I. SPOKE HELLO LONG
MISTER HUNTER- YESTERDAY- AFTER
A HIATUS IN OUR CONVERSATIONS
WE ALONG AND I THINK POSITIVE
CONVERSE GEN WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS I
AM COMMITTED. HAS ALWAYS TO
WORKING WITH THE TRADE THEM UP.
IT RE TO WRESTLE HERE BECAUSE
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR EVERYONE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS FRANK WE
NEED AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS
WELL. AS HER COLLEAGUES WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. WITH OR NOT NOT
THE WITH ME WITH IN SPIRIT AND
ON THE PHONE TODAY OUR TWO
WITNESSES THE RIVER BERMAN JOHN
HARVEY TAYLOR. WHO IS THE
BISHOP OF THE EPISCOPAL DIOCESE
OF LOS ANGELES. AND THE NEEDS
WHEN TWO IS ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF ONE RESPONSE THERE
IS A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
HOUSING. AND IS ALSO WITH AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- DEVELOPER
EA H. HOUSING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO THE MODERATOR LET'S GO
TO THE WITNESSES ARE ON THE
LINE LET'S GO FIRST TO DENISE
WENT. IT CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DENISE WHEN AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPMENT AT THE AGE HOUSING
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT E. EIGHT HOUSING IS ONE
OF THE LIKE. NONPROFIT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND MANAGEMENT
ORGANIZATION IN THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES WE MANAGE MORE
THAN ELEVEN THOUSAND UNIT
LEASES AND SEVENTY EIGHT
MINUTES THE PALLIPES AND KEPT
AND CAL AND HAWAII. OTHER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE I STRONG
FEEL SB EIGHT NINETY NINE. AND
ALSO HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE AND
I'M NOT. HOUSING AS CAMP I AM A
BOY MEMBER AT CAMP BUT THERE AT
THE COLLECTIVE WAY FOR A
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH MORE
THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS.
SCANS STRONGLY SUPPORT SB EIGHT
NINETY NINE AND IT'S A WHOLE
FIVE THAT THE BILL. THIS BILL
CREATES HOUSING SOLUTION FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. AT FIFTY
EIGHT NINETY NINE WILL MAKE
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
EASIER FASTER AND LESS
EXPENSIVE FOR THAT THEY STATE
INSTITUTION. AND NONPROFIT
COLLEGES THAT WANT TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THANK OF
WORSHIP AND COLLEGE THAT WE TO
HOME. SEC UNDER YOUR BILL
LÏNG SHOULD BE LIMITED
DELAYED OR PREVENTED FROM MAKE
TAKING ACTION. WE NEED TO PASS
AT THE EIGHT NINETY NINE TO
HELP MAKE OUR COMMUNITY
STRONGER AND MORE INCLUSIVE ON
MONDAY THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
EDITORIAL BOARD PUBLISHED AN
ENDORSEMENT OF SB EIGHT NINETY
NINE. THE EDITORIAL TITLED
CAPTURED IN CALIFORNIA THE
HOME. THAT HIGH AND THE HOUSES
OF WORSHIP HAVE LAND. TOGETHER
LET'S MAKE THE MOST OF THAT
LAND AS CAMPUS MEMBERS KNOW
FIRST HAND THAT AFFORDABLE
RENTAL HOUSING IS THE
CORNERSTONE TO EQUITABLE
SUSTAINABLE LIVING CAN BE A-
PLEASE APPROVED SB EIGHT NINE
NINE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S HEAR
FROM THE SECOND WHEN THIS TO
THE BISHOP A JOHN TAYLOR- AND
AS THE MODERATOR TO ALLOW SPEAK.
YEAH WAS CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M JOHN HARVEY
TAYLOR OF THE ACOUSTICAL DIES
BUT D'ANGELO WHICH COMPRISES
BUT CHANGE YOUR ORANGE VENTURA
SANTA BARBARA NUMBER TWO YOU
KNOW COUNTY PART OF RIVERSIDE-
TO INSTITUTIONS ALTOGETHER
INCLUDING A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FOUR CHURCH. ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND. THE HIGH COST OF
HOUSING IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AFFECTS EVERY INDIVIDUAL AND
FAMILY IN EVERYONE OF OUR
CHURCHES AND NEIGHBORHOODS. THE
ON HOW HOUSING INSTRUCTOR ARE
YOUR GREATEST CONCERN I AS WELL
AS OUR WHAT WE THINK IS WELL OF
YOUNG PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO PUT
DOWN ROOTS THE END UP MOVING
OUT OF OUR STATE. RETIREE WE
HAVE TO MOVE AWAY FROM THEIR
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN. TO
HELP ADDRESS THE PRICE OF. OUR
CHURCHES HAVE AN ASPECT WE CAN
OFFER OUR COMMUNITY IS TO THE
GLORY OF GOD. AND FOR THE SAKE
OF THE NEIGHBORS FOR COMMANDER
COME UP. REAL ESTATE ON MANY OF
OUR CHURCH THIS. FOR PORTABLE
PERMANENT SUPPORT OF. FOR
SENIORS AND VETERANS. WE HAVE
SEVERAL PROJECTS IN THE WAY
ALREADY IN OR NOT SB EIGHT
NINETY NINE WILL ENABLE US WITH
VISION MORE EACH PROJECT
ANOTHER PLACE FOR PEOPLE THE
LATER. ALL OF OUR IF YOU WANT
TO BE GOOD NEIGHBORS THEIR
NEIGHBOR. WE WANT THE PROJECT
WE PRACTICE SAFE AND SECURE FOR
EVERYONE. BUT FOOD AND NOW
HOUSING JOBS THAT IS THE
CENTRAL CHURCH MINISTRY
ESPECIALLY IN THE SPEND THEM AT
ARMS SB EIGHT NINETY NINE WILL
MAKE IT EASIER FOR CHURCH TO DO
WHT'S MORE. AND I THINK
GENERAL LEARN AS ALI AND URGES.
THANK. THANK YOU WHEN A GO TO
OTHER. MEMBERS OF THE ON THE
LINE WHO WISHED SUPPORT THE
BILL. THE LADY THAT IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
NINE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. NCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE MOMENT
THE CHAIR. ONE ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS EVEN STRONGER
WITH THE BAY AREA HOW THE
ADVOCACY COALITION. AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. I WANT TO THREE YOUR
LINE IS A- PLEASE CALL. TIFFANY
FAN ON THE OF HOUSE IT'S A
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN
MEMBER ADAM. AT AMENDED THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IMPORT. I NUMBER TWO NINETY
FIVE YOUR IS ALL PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR KAREN
MEMBERS THAT THE LACK OF
CREATING ON THE OF SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME IS THE PORT
THANK YOU. NUMBER TWO NINETY
EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS DEBORAH CARLTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT.
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
TWO EIGHTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR KAREN MEMBERS
STILL CAN'T BELIEVE SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NUMBER ONE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE FIVE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
A MUCH DIVERSE OF THE CALL. A
PARTNERSHIP INSTEAD WIENER AT
EIGHT. MY NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON CHEN
LEVEL. I'M NOT A NOT. I AM
HEARING AT ELEVEN ECHO WITH HER.
THANK YOU ACT OKAY LADEN NOT A
WHOLE PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF THREE PEOPLE LIKE AND
WHICH INCLUDES AFFECT
FOUNDATION- PARTNER. OTHER
HOUSING ADVOCATES OF BRINGING
ADD BALD HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA AND HELP POVERTY
AND- AND WHAT. YOU IN LINE TWO
THIRTY THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. STEPHANIE
ANDERSON AND WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT I CAN THE NATION APART.
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
MIND IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
CHIU AN HONORABLE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS DIFFERENT GOT A
YEAR WITH BURBANK HOUSING OUT
OF CINEMA NAPA COUNTY. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NUMBER ONE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ELLIE THE A
VIGIL ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT. NUMBER TWO
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I TO THE ONE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE. I
NUMBER TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN TO FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU.
HI MY NAME IS GABRIELLE
RELEASED ON BEHALF OF TENDERLY
NEIGHBORHOOD DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION AND WE'RE IN COULD
PART THANK YOU. NUMBER TWO
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE'LL BE IDEAL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS IN SUPPORT.
NUMBER TWO EIGHTEEN THE LINE IS
OPEN TO EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NUMBER TWO
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
ELIZABETH KAWADA ON BEHALF MARK
THE HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. I NUMBER ONE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COUNTRY. DAVID
INVOLVED ON BEHALF OF BUILT
WORKABLE FASTER CALIFORNIA.
COULD BE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FOR BOTH THE NONPROFIT I'LL BE
PROVIDED WHICH GROUP I THINK
THE APPROACH WHAT. THANK YOU.
NINE THREE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS THIS IS
ERIC JOHNSON WITH
REHABILITATION RESTORATION
ARREST BUT THE CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HELLO THANK YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MICHAEL GOT IN THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING NEAR THE STOVE NEWS
THANK. AND THEN WILL YIELD
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BUYING TWO EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PHILLIP BURNS WITH THE ARROYO
GROUP WELL WORKING. WITH TWENTY
SIX CONGREGATIONS AND EIGHT
JURISDICTION OF ONE THING CAL
THAT WANT TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON THEIR LAND AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. AND ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS BOB NAY LARA.
REPRESENTING DEALS THE COMPANY
AN ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS ON
SUPPORT OF THE UNOFFICIAL USED
PROPERTY. I'M THREE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THREE ONE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ALEX WORKED WITH A
HOUSING ORGANIZATION AND
SUPPORT. I TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU EIGHT SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M TO
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
NUMBER OF THE TO THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA. WE WERE. ONE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE FERRARI ON
BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT.
THANK THREE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
TERM WHICH TO MISTER TERM
MEMBERS- LUIS MARACAY ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT. I'M TO
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN TWO
NINE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
PAUL YODER HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. LINE THREE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE ATOM REALISM
YEAH THE RULING IF YOU WERE
CALLING TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I DO UNDERSTAND THERE
IS A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO
IS AT ONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS SO IF I
COULD ASK. FOR THAT TO BE
ACTIVATED. PLEASE PROCEED.
STORES WITH STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF UP FOR
GROWTH ACTION CALIFORNIA AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WITH THAT NOW LET'S
GO TO WITNESSES AND THE
OPPOSITION I KNOW WE'VE GOT TO
WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE. AND I
WILL ASK THE OPERATOR TO FIRST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT ERIN LET HAN.
I WANTED TO OPEN. ACTUALLY
SHE'S HEARING ON. MITCHELL HAD.
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME OK WE
CAN GET WHERE I'M SUPPOSED TO
BE GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN TO
AN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ARE IN MY HAND AND I'M
IN HERE'S WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING. OPPOSITION
TO SB EIGHT NINE NINE. BUT I'M
ASSUMING YOU GUYS READ THE BILL
THIS BILL IS ALMOST LIMITLESS
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT A NON NON
TAX PAYING COLLEGES AND
CHURCHES. THIS IS A BY RIGHT
BILL AND THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
THE BUILDING TRADES AND SUPPORT
BY RIGHT. BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN
CONDITIONS THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE INCLUDING THE PROTECTION
OF WORKERS THE ENVIRONMENT AND
THE COMMUNITY. AND TO MAKE ALL
EFFORTS TO PREVENT THE
GENTRIFICATION OF COMMUNITY.
THE BUILDING TRADES IN
CALIFORNIA PROBABLY HAVE
ALREADY RAMPED UP APPRENTICE.
WE WERE PRETTY RAMPED UP
APPRENTICE PROBABLY THE MOST
ROBUST ROBUST AND DIVERSE
APPRENTICESHIP IN THE COUNTRY.
72% OF CALIFORNIA'S APPRENTICES
OF SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND FOR
APPRENTICES EXCUSE ME ARE
PEPLE OF COLOR. ONE IN FIVE
COME OUT OF PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED EMANCIPATED USE
ARE THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. MY
FAVORITE STATISTIC OF ALL THE
WOMEN IN APPRENTICESHIPS IN THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA 95%
OF THAT ARE IN THE BUILDING
TRADES. IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN TO
AN APPRENTICE CENTER IN
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN SMELL THE
OPPORTUNITY. KIDS FROM THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED IN THE STATE
COMING TOGETHER LEARNING A
TRADE GETTING A PROFESSION THAT
WILL PROVIDE HEALTH BENEFITS
AND RETIREMENT BENEFITS. IT
WILL ALLOW THE- WE THAT ALLOW
EVEN HEARING CALIFORNIA NOW IF
WE TALK ABOUT HOUSING TO AFFORD
A HOME. TO SHELTER THEIR OWN
FAMILIES. THE ONLY THING THAT
WE ASK FOR AND THIS BILL IS
SKILLED AND TRAINED LANGUAGE
LANGUAGE THAT OF SUPPORTS ARE
VERY. VERY DIVERSE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA. ATTY JUST ADDING
SKILLED IN TRAINS IT'S NOT
INCREASE THE COST. OF HOUSING
PROGRAM BECAUSE THESE ARE
PREVAILING WAGE PROJECTS DOES
THAT ADD A PENNY SO I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE IF WE WERE SITTING HERE
TODAY TALKING ABOUT A PROGRAM
THAT WOULDN'T COST ANYTHING.
ALLOW KIDS FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE A PATH TO FREE COLLEGE
EDUCATION WE PROBABLY HAVE A
LINE OUT THE DOOR EVEN TODAY
MAYBE NOT. ON BEHALF OF THE
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING TRADES. WE ASK THAT
YOU HOLD THIS BILL AND DO NOT
MOVE IT FORWARD UNTIL IT
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT. SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND APPRENTICES. AND
INCLUDES TRAINED WORKFORCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET'S GO
TO THE SECOND ONE THIS SHANNON
O'HARE. HIS HAND ON HER ONLINE
OR SOME REPRESENTING THE MARIN
COUNTY COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND
COUNCIL MEMBERS. TO THE
MODERATOR. RIGHT THE. ONE
SENATE OVER HERE NOT ON THE
LINE ONE. WHO ELSE WOULD BE ON
THE LINE FOR HER HERE. SENATOR
HERE OR PROXY FROM THE MARIN
COUNTY COUNCIL MAYORS IF NO ONE
IS ON THE LINE THEN. WE'LL JUST
GO TO OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
IN OPPOSITION AD IF THERE'S A
IF THERE'S AN INDIVIDUAL
REPRESENT A MARIN COUNTY. WE'LL
HEAR FROM YOU AT THAT TIME. SO
TO THE MATTER IF YOU COULD OPEN
UP THE LINE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT
NINETY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT
NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS AND
THEN THERE NOW. ONE MOMENT HERE.
LINE. ONE THIRTY THREE ONE
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT LIKE
TRAITS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
WITHOUT AMENDMENT THANK YOU. IN
ONE MOMENT THE CHAIR. NUMBER
FORTY ONE ONE MOMENT THE TIER
ONE. NINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON OR THE CHAIR WHERE
THE BOARD MEMBER. HI MY CAN
THEIR OWN WITH MODERATE
SHANKER'S COUNTY BILL
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BE. EIGHT
NINE NINE. WHERE DID THEY HAVE
THAT LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL THE
SKILLED TRAINED WORKFORCE. OUR
APPRENTICESHIPS ARE SECOND TO
NONE THEY'RE THE BEST IN YOU
NEED THE YOUNG PEOPLE TAKE-
WORKS I'M AN OLD GUY AND I'M
GOING OUT. WHEN WE MEET THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT COME IN AND
THEN THERE ARE ARE CREDITED.
REDUCTION PROGRAMS. THANK YOU.
I NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
SIXTY. GOOD AFTERNOON TWENTIETH
CENTURY I AGREE W. LOCAL ELEVEN
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. WE HAVE
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND A CREDIT
THAT ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN LA COUNTY OVER ôNG
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. MY MOM THE CHAIR. ONE
FIFTY SIX. ONE MOMENT. LINE ONE
FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS LYNETTE MCELROY AND I
REPRESENT WESTERN. OF NORTH
PARK IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES AND
GREAT BIRD AVENUE BLOCK CLUB WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED. TO BUY WHITE LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT THE CHAIR.
THE NORMAL FOR DIFFERENT. ONE
MOMENT. ONE ONE OH SEVEN THE
LINE IS OPEN LINE ONE ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT
NUMBERS MY NAME IS KATHLEEN SO
I'M BUSINESS AGENT WITH LOCAL
SIXTEEN HUMOR PROCESS LETTERS I
REPRESENT OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
MEMBERS NOT A CALIFORNIA.
FAMILY STRONGLY OPPOSED. ALONG
WITH. TWO TWENTY FOUR THE LINE
IS OPEN TWO TWO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIRMAN
CHIU AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I'M
RON MILLER EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
OF THE LA ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND SKILLED AND TRAINED
MEN AND WOMEN OF THE BUILDING
TRADES IN LA IN ORANGE COUNTY
INCLUDING ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND OF PREMISES. WE HIGHLY
OPPOSE THIS THIS BILL AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE SENATE TO
COMPLETE THOSE PATHWAYS TO A
GOOD MIDDLE CLASS CAREER. THANK
YOU. I AM SIXTY ONE. SIX ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN DOWN ON
BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED BUILDERS
AND CONTRACTORS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE ELECT AMENDED POSITION
AS TO THE PROVISION THAT
IMPOSES REQUIREMENTS THAT DON'T
APPLY IF THEY'RE THE PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS AND IFAC THANK
YOU. ONE EIGHTY TWO WE'RE NOT
IN OPEN ONE EIGHT TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON ANASTACIO
ANNAPOLIS SAN FRANCISCO TENANTS
UNION I'M OPPOSED TO THIS BY
RIGHT GENTRIFIED CATION BILL.
AND STAND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING TRADES AND ALL THE
REST OF THE TRADES PEOPLE THANK
YOU. ONE MOMENT THE CHAIR.
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M OPPOSED TO THIS BECAUSE I
AM A SINGLE FAMILY HOME OWNER I
HAVEN'T HEARD MANY HOMEOWNERS
ON THIS BUT I'M OPPOSE THIS
BECAUSE IT AFFECTS LOCAL ZONING
WHICH THEN ALLOWS IN ROADS INTO
CHANGING LOCAL ZONING SO THAT
WE CAN THEN DEVELOPERS CAN COME
IN AND- PUT APARTMENT BUILDINGS
AND EVERYTHING IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD SO I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS. ON THANKS VERY MUCH. SIX
ONE NEXTQUESTION OR- COMES
FROM A LINE OF THREE TWENTY
SEVEN. THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE
TOO MANY CRISTINA I'M ON BEHALF
OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD MOTOR MAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. OF REQUESTING THE
AMENDMENTS FOR STILL INTRIGUED
LOOK FOR. AND NEXT IS TO NINETY
SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHAIRMAN DANNY CURTAIN ONCE
AGAIN FOR CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE
OF. I EXPRESS ON BEHALF OF THE
CARPENTERS AT SUPPORT FOR THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THESE HOUSING
BILLS INCLUDING EIGHT NINE NINE.
POURTANT ABBIA THEY MUST
INCLUDE AS STATED BY GAVIN
NEWSOM IN HIS- THE HOUSING
PORTION OF THIS MAY REVISED
MESSAGE AND THIS IS CRITICAL
BUILDING A WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGY TO SUPPORT
THE SKILLED AND TRAINED HOUSING
WORKFORCE PIPELINE WITH HIGH
WAGE HIGH. WAGE RATS AND
PROMOTING INNOVATIVE
ALTERNATIVE CONSTRUCTION
METHODS WE SUPPORT THIS BILL IF
THAT NATURE IS IN THERE THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE. TIMES WERE GOOD
POLICY MAY HAVE. NEXT COMES
FROM MINE THREE THIRTY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. UNDER FELLOW- AND
HAVE AND WHAT THE MAN AND BEING
PROPOSED BY THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT. COMES
FROM TWO NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT. THE NEXT
COMES FROM THE LINE. TWO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STEVEN
GOMEZ I AM REPRESENTING THE
PLUMBERS INSTINCT THERE'S A
LOCAL FOR SIXTY I REPRESENT
SEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS AND ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE APPRENTICES AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL. IN THE
NEXT LINE NUMBER IS. ONE
THIRTEEN. HIGHLY SKILLED AND
TRAINED WOMEN AND MEN OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THE NEXT LINE NUMBER
IS ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JOHN CORE SO I'M A
REPRESENTATIVE WITH YOU A LOCAL
THIRTY EIGHT CLIMBERS INSTINCT
BUT ISN'T THAT PROCESS COMO
ALSO A DELEGATE TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BUILDING TRADES. WE
HIGHLY OPPOSE SB EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ON THE
NEXT LINE THAT'S GOING TO BE
OPEN AS TO EIGHTEEN. MY NAME
THAT I REPRESENTED AT
REPRESENTED THE CEMENT MASONS A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. NOW WE
HAVE THE DILLON TATE- PER SHIP
IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF SKILLED
WORKERS. WE'RE OPPOSED TO AND
BE EIGHT NINE NINE HUNDRED.
THAT'D KEVIN TRAIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NECKLINE THAT IS
GOING TO BE OPEN IS THREE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE MOLLY GONNA
BE UP THE CALIFORNIA STATE HIGH
PRIEST COUNCIL THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS. WESTERN CENTER COUNCIL
OF SHEET METAL WORKERS. AND THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION THE
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SB EIGHT THIRTY
NINE. LET THE BILL AS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE SKILLED INCORRECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT
LINE OPENNESS FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S BRIAN
HOLD PROUD MEMBER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
AND STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU LINE NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE NINE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DIGITAL HERE YOU'LL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
NEIGHBORS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT COUNCIL. YOU REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN TORRANCE CALIFORNIA
AND THE BOYS ARE OPPOSITION TO
AS AN EIGHT NINETY NINE. IT IS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT THE CHAIR.
MY NUMBER. SEVENTY EIGHT THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH MY NAME IS JIM. I AM A
BUSINESS OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS LOCAL FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN KERN COUNTY WE ARE
STANDING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION SB EIGHT NINETY NINE
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBERTWO
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS MAP RIDE
I ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS I JUST LIKE THAT LINE
OUR COMMENTS WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES AND URGE CENTER WIENER-
TAKE DOCTOR GOLDEN TRAINED
WORKFORCE LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHTY THREE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN LINE EIGHT THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
SHE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND AMERICA IN THE NORTHEASTERN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
STANDING IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA THE BUILDING TRADES.
ASKING THAT THE COMMITTEE HOLD
THIS BILL UNTIL UNTRAINED
LANGUAGES INSERTED INTO THE.
NINE ONE NINETY FOUR THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BATTLE FOR LOW
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
AND LIFE LONG SENTENCES CAN LAW
I'M CALLING TO OPPOSE SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY NINE UNLESS
IT'S AMENDED WITH THE FILM
CURRENT WORKFORCE LANGUAGE THEY
ARE. I AM EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BOB. MY WITH MY KENNER I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE- BROTHER OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL TWO
THIRTY FOUR WHICH IS MONTEREY
SANTA CRUZ IN TâM BENITO
COUNTY. WHICH WE ARE A SKILLED
TRAINED WORK FORCE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE. EIGHT NINETY NINE AS
WRITTEN IN LOW SKILLED AND
TRAINED ADDED. INTO THE
LANGUAGE THANK YOU. LINE TWO
EIGHTY ONE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
BILL. HONORABLE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS JAMES BUT I'M SPEAK
ARABIC AT. BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCT A- IS COMPRISED OF
SUCTION UNIONS. SIXTEEN
THOUSAND. MENTAL WEBMAIL WE
STAND IN THIRTY WITH STATE. IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL- AMENDED
TO INCLUDE SKILLED. FORCE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ONE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JULIE AND I HAD A BILL FOR
PRESENTED BEGINNERS NOW A TRADE
DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY SIX.
FIFTY TWO WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE BELIEVE A
100% KILLED TRAINED WORKFORCE
WHICH PROVIDE JOB OPPORTUNITIES
TO OUR MEMBERS INCLUDING PROPER
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING ON THE
JOB IN RETURN THE END USER.
NINE ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS FRED
LIMóN ON BEHALF OF PLUMBERS
INSTINCT THAT OUR LOCAL NUMBER
THREE FORTY THREE JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINETY NINE. THANK YOU. I
NUMBER NINETY NINE ZERO YOUR
MIND OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS MATTER
ON THE BUSINESS AGENTS- LOCAL
THREE HUNDRED CHAPTERS SYSTEM
THAT MADE THE MEASURE
CALIFORNIA- JOURNEY OF
SOLIDARITY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BILLION TRADE. IN THEIR
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
NINE NINE ALL OF AMENDED TO A-
NEED SKINNER TRAINED. NUMBER
TWO FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO FIVE NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS DECLINED ONLY
CALIFORNIA CITY WE'RE
OFFICIALLY- CLOSENESS MAJOR
SOARED OVER WRITER STATE
CERTIFIED HOUSING. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON I'M NICK CARDY WITH
YOU A LOCAL ONE FOURTEEN- SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY PLUMBERS
PIPEFITTERS HVAC TAX AND WHILE
THERE IS I WILL BE JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL DUE TO
LACK OF THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
TO PROVISIONS IN THE BILL. LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE
THREE FIVE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
JERRY MEMBERS ON JOHNSON
JOHNSON ON BEHALF POSITION FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES EXPRESSING CONCERN
REGARDING SB EIGHT NINETY NINE-
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN CONVERSATION
WITH THE OF A DOCTOR'S OFFICE I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK HIM FOR HIS
CONSIDERATION OF POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS TO PREVENT
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON. THE COMPUTER RIGHT.
I'M SUCH AS THE FOR DOING
FIGHTING. POINT TO PLEASE JUST
EXPRESSED HER NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT OF
YOUR OPPOSITION. NEXT WEEK OR.
I NUMBER. SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS CHRIS. FROM
THE CHAIR. ONE ONE ONE FIFTY
FOUR NINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS NOT ON BUT YOU WERE LOCAL
ONE FIVE NINE PROMISE KEEPERS
PERTAINS CALIFORNIA. APPLE THE
MINIMUM A LOCAL ONE FIVE NINE
STAND STAPLING TRAITS TO OPPOSE
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINE NINE.
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWO SIX TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
PAUL THE TERROR THE NUMBER OF
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL TO
THIRTY FOUR AND ALSO A GRADUATE
OF THE LOCAL THE PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM. WE DAN AND JOIN HUNTER
AND THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHT NINETY NINE
WITHOUT THE SKILLED TRADES
WORKFORCE LANGUAGE. LINE TWO
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO FOR
THEIR ALWAYS GO AHEAD. DANIEL
REPRESENTING THE INDIGO IRON
WORKERS LOCAL THE FINAL. BEING
WITH THE STATE INSURANCE IN
OPPOSITION AT EIGHT NINE ONE.
THANK YOU EIGHTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TO EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
MEMBERS CARE OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF
MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. NINE
ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME. IS MARK TO BUILD
BUSINESS AGENT WITH THE HEAT
INTO LOCAL SIXTEEN ORDER TO. I
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADE COUNCIL IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
IS WRITTEN SKILLED UPGRADE WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DANNY BURKE BUT LOCAL UNION
THREE FORTY THREE UPON
RESISTING FETTERS NAPA SOLANO
COUNTY AND WE ARE JOINING THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. LINE
FORTY EIGHT LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOHN MORALIS- VICE PRESIDENT
TEAMSTERS LOCAL EIGHTY SEVEN
FOR THE KERN COUNTY AREA AND WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL SB
EIGHT NINETY NINE THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOHN HENRY LOPEZ THE
UNITED ASSOCIATION PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX
REPRESENTING FRESNO MADERA KING
ON AND I WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK REAL ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RODRIGUEZ I WORKERS LOCAL FOUR
THIRTY THREE. WE POSES BILL
WROTE. LINE TWO TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JOHN
DOUGHERTY BUSINESS MANAGER IBEW
LOCAL SECTION SAN FRANCISCO.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE THREE
THOUSAND PLUS MEMBERS AND
WORKING FAMILIES I IN OUR LOCAL
WE ASK- WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES YES WITH THIS
ITEM BE HELD OVER. SO THAT.
THERE CAN BE RISEN. WITH THE
STATE TRADE. OR OTHERWISE WE
OPPOSE THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN GOOD LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THERE ARE CERTAIN
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
TWELVE WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL. LOCAL FRONT. OP I
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CHRIS LETTER WITH THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL FLEET THREE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR AND WE URGE
THE OFFER TO WORK WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES- TO AMEND THE
BILL- IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
POINT. THANK YOU. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN NINETEEN YEAR LINE IS OKAY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOOK LIKE THE
DISCONNECT WHY ONE OH EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE ZERO EIGHT. ONE ZERO
EIGHT YOUR BILL BEEN. THE CHAIR.
ONE ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE FOUR SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT AFTER THEFAMILY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME SPEAK MY NAME IS RJ FOR ARE
YOU THAT THE THREAT FROM LOCAL
THIRTY EIGHT MEMBERS OF
PIPEFITTERS DAMPENED CISCO AND
A PROUD MEMBER OF THE BUILDING.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB EIGHT NINE
NINE. AND I LOVE TO HOLD THE
BILL. FOR THE PROTECTION OF OUR
WORKERS. WHAT. THREE THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN THREE THREE
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS ROSE I'M CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF YOU A LOCAL FIVE
EIGHTY TWO IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHT NINE. ONE OF THE CHAIR.
IT SPEAKERS IT PLEASE PRESS ANY
BUTTON ON YOUR PHONE. WHY
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHY NUMBER THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NUMBER THREE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD THREE TWENTY
SIX. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. WE WERE ABLE
TO HELP HOMEOWNERS MANAGE. ONE
MOMENT THE CHAIR. THE CHAIR.
ONE THREE TWENTY SIX FIFTY BACK
UP ONE ONE TWO ONE THREE THIRTY
FOUR LINE THREE THREE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A LINE OF GOLD
IN. HELLO MY NAME IS SCOTT BILL
I REPRESENT NUMBERS PARTNERS
WELL THERE'S AN HVAC WORKERS IN
SAN MATTEO COUNTY GIVEN THE
ABSENCE OF LANGUAGE MANDATING
SKILLED AND TRAINED LABOR WE
OPPOSE. SB NINETY NINE AS
WRITTEN THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS GRETCHEN
THERE'S SOME ON BEHALF OF IBEW
FIVE SIX NINE IN OUR THIRTY
FOUR HUNDRED ELECTRICIANS
THROUGHOUT SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
COLLEEN AND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THEBILL UNTIL A
MINIATURE KILLED IN TRAINED
WORKFORCE AREN'T MEANT THAT
ACCEPTED. NINE TO SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO SEVEN
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIKE YOU
CAN EITHER YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES. WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE THREE
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ONE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE WOMAN WITH
THE CHAIR. MY ONE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO ON
ONE TWENTY ONE. LINE ONE NINETY
FIVE ONE MOMENT EVERYONE. LINE
ONE NINE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DAVID LATELY A LOS ANGELES
ABOUT AN ECHO ON HERE THANK YOU
TO THE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND- TRADESPEOPLE
PROPOSING THIS. KELLY AND SIXTY
THOUSAND OF THEM NEED TO FIND
OUT WHAT BY RIGHT DOES THE
NEIGHBORHOODS REGRADING-
DECADES LONG ANGER AT OWNERS
AND RENTERS BY RIGHT NEEDS TO
COME OUT OF THIS DENSITY BONUS
NEEDS TO COME OUT. BECAUSE NAY
I COULD HARDLY STAND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR. I'M JUST GONNA
REMIND FOLKS AGAIN PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND- JUST SAY OPPOSE. MODERATOR
THANK YOU CHAIRED BYONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
NINE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MICHAEL MARK ON THE
ACCESS TO THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES. AND
OPPOSED AS WELL AS OUR MEMBERS
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. ONE THREE THIRTY FIVE A
LINE IS OPEN THREE THREE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS. TAYLOR AND THE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM OF THE WEST TO LOOK A
LAKE RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION AND
WE OPPOSE THAT SB EIGHT NINETY
NINE AND LET THE MEN DIDN'T
MANY NONPROFITS BOTH. NINE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE THIRTY
THREE ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
EIGHT TO OUR CAR REPRESENTS
THEM SO COUNTY ELECTRICIANS
UNION LOCAL SIX SEVENTEEN WE
OPPOSE. THIS BILL SB EIGHT NINE
NINE. NINE TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO ONE OF THEIR OLD PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU AND YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MICHAEL
KONIG A HOMEOWNER AND SUNSET
WHERE A HISTORIC PRESERVATION
OVERLAID SO. I OPPOSE THIS AND
ALL OTHER BILLS THAT DO DAMAGE
TO OUR HISTORIC NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND. LINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN LINE FIVE EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
CHAIN BOSTON PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR EIGHT
FOUR IN VENTURA WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
STRONGLY OPPOSES BE EIGHT
NINETY NINE IS WRITTEN. THANK.
HOME. NINE ONE SIX ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
NINE ONE SIXTY. HI. IN AND
ARMAND OKAY MISTER CAN MEMBERS
THIS IS KATE ON HIT AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABOR
WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS. THANK
YOU LINE THREE FIFTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHEN GOVERNOR FORMER RONALD
WITH THE LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
I'M CALLING INTO A POST IN THE
BILL EIGHT NINE NINE AND THAT'S
IT HAS THE SKILLED AND PRINT
WORK FORCE THANK YOU. MY MOM IS
THE CHAIR LINE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE FIFTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS BEEN THAT LOW IN AND
FORTY OF THE COVER ALSO
CALIFORNIA. I'M JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES TO OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. IN LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT. ONE
MOMENT THE CHAIR. HOME. ONE
SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CHRIS GRAINY
WITH THE SACRAMENTO SIERRA-
BUILDING TRADES AND WE STAND
WITH STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION SB EIGHT NINE NINE.
THANK YOU. LINE THREE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN ONE
THREE FIVE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THREE FIFTEEN YEAR LOW IS
OPEN. DAVID ANSEN LOCAL THREE
NINETY EIGHT REPRESENTING A ONE
THOUSAND FORTY ONE FAMILIES AND
I STAND IN OPPOSITION OF THE-
OF SB EIGHT NINETY NINE THANK.
ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO. MY NAME IS TOM
WHAT MAN I GREW UP IN A
PORTABLE OUT I CURRENTLY. DO
YOUR LARGEST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMPLEX. I GO ALL THE BY THE
ABILITY TRAY YEAH IN ALL IT WAS
TO. JUST. THANK YOU AND YOUR
AND SUPPORTER OF AS A- THANK
YOU NEXT WHAT. LINE ONE ZERO
EIGHT YOU'RE GOING TO GO WHILE
OH EIGHT. RIGHT THIS IS JOE
CRICKET. I REPRESENT THE LOCAL
I. B. W. ONE EIGHTY FOR NAPA
SOLANO. AND WE ALONG WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES OPPOSE.
SB EIGHT NINE NINE THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUDGET
DIRECTOR MARTIN SO THAT MAKES
US LOCAL FOUR HUNDRED IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES WE
OPPOSE A. B. I MEAN SB AT EIGHT
NINE NINE THANK YOU. LINE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY NUMBER
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS- ROD
CLOSE BUSINESS MANAGER WITH THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FACTORY
REPRESENTING OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND- MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WE STRONGLY OPPOSE-
SB. EIGHT NINE NINE. THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JACK BUT CORN WITH THE
NORTH STATE BUILDING TRADES I
WILL CLOSE WE ARE SB IS NINETY
NINE LOS AMENDED TO INCLUDE
CERTAIN TRYING THANK YOU. LINE
THREE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THREE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS BERNADETTE BACKWARDS
WITH UNITED SITUATION A PLUMBER
IN BETTER BOOK LEADING TO
THIRTY REPRESENTING ABOUT
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED SKILLED MEN
AND WOMEN OF THE AMERICAN
PICKETING TRADE AND TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY FOUR PROMISES AND WE
FAN IN OPPOSITION SB EIGHT AND
NINE. LINE ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE THIRTY GET
OUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS MORGAN OLD EIGHT ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE WESTERN
DISTRICT COUNCIL OF RIVERS
WATER PERVERSION ALLIED WORKERS
AND WE'RE STANDING WITH THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
CONSTRUCTION TRADE HOME. ON
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT NINE
NINE THANK YOU. LINE THREE
SIXTY FIVE YOURLINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JIM
PAULSEN SECRETARY TREASURER OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WITHOUT HAVING THE SKILLED
WORKFORCE LANGUAGE IN IT THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY WE THOROUGHLY
OPPOSED EIGHT NINETY NINE AND
GO. AND ASK PEOPLE TO REJECT
THE SPECT. LINE ONE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY ONE FORTY SIX ALIGN
IT OPEN. PINE THREE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THREE THREE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHT THREE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
AND MY APOLOGIES I BELIEVE I
WAS CUT OFF EARLIER IF THE
MARINE ALLIANCE BUT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BELLS
AND- CONCERNED ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS BEING PROPOSED BY
THE OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI AS A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF SUSTAINABLE FAIRFAX I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND IF THE
CARE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS ARE MISSED
QUIRK SILVA. YES I APPRECIATE
THE THIS BILL AS WAS NOTED WE
ARE IN AN EIGHT EXCLUSION
REGARDING HOUSING WE HAVE TO
DO- MORE. QUICKLY AGGRESSIVELY
AND WE HAVE TO BUILD. THAT WE
CAN ON POTENTIALLY USE LAND
THAT HAS NOT BEEN USED BEFORE
TO BUILD IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND I THINK
VERY INNOVATIVE. HOWEVER I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL BUT
REALLY URGE YOU TO WORK WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES TO BUT THE
SKILLED LANGUAGE UP. IN THIS
BILL- BECAUSE IF IT DOES COME
BACK TO THE FLOOR OF WITHOUT
WORKING OUT WITH THE TRADES I
CANNOT PROMISE I WOULD SUPPORT
IT THERE. BUT I'D ALSO URGE OUR
FRIENDS ON BOTH SIDES THE
OPPOSING SIDE AND THE
SUPPORTING SIDE TO KNOW THAT WE
ALL HAVE TO COME TO THE TABLE
AND LOOK FOR WAYS THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER. IN ORDER. TO GET
BUILDING DONE FOR THESE HOW NOW
WILL CONTINUE TAKING. AND THAT
MEANS PEOPLE SLEEPING ON
CORNERS THAT MEANS PEOPLE
SLEEPING IN CARS THAT MEANS
PEOPLE AND PARKS AND IT MEANS
AN ADDITIONAL ONLY A THREAD OF
A COVERT VIRUS EXPLODING AS WE
SEE THAT AS PEOPLE ARE OUT ON
THE STREETS THAT NO SANITARY
PLACE FOR THEM. TO USE ARRAY.
RESTROOM IN ADDITION TO CHANGE
HANDS ANY NOW. SO THAT
IMPERATIVE THE WE GET OF. THE
TOP RIGHT NOW I KNOW. THAT TO.
CORD WE WANT EVERY EGGS THE WAY
WE WILL IT BUT HAVE TO COME TO
THE- MAKES AMONG. THAT ARE
LOOKING AT A PANDEMIC PERIOD
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU MR GRUBER. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND NOT
REALLY ENCOURAGED BY WHAT YOU
SAID AT THE BEGINNING ABOUT
YOUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES- YOU KNOW REALLY HOPE
THAT THOSE CONVERSATIONS WILL
CONTINUE AT THIS TO ME IS THE
KIND OF THOUGHTFUL AND
INNOVATIVE POLICY THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS ND HOPEFUL
THAT THE THAT THIS IS THE KIND
OF THING THAT EVERYBODY CAN GET
BEHIND AND SUPPORT BECAUSE THIS
IS THE THESE ARE THE KIND OF
SOLUTIONS THAT WE NEED. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT
TO ADD A PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE
HERE IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR ONE
OF THE CALL ONE OF THE- THE
WITNESSES I GUESS MENTION THE
EDITORIAL IN THE IN THE LA
TIMES ABOUT THE BILL ENDORSING
THE BILL. I'M NOT IT OPENS BY
TALKING ABOUT THE VISION OF MY
RABBI- IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD AND
SEE AND MY DOG IN ENCINO VALLEY
BACHELOR WHERE I'M VERY PROUD
TO BE A MEMBER THE COMMUNITY OR
MY KIDS GO TO SCHOOL AND IT'S A
PLACE THAT IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MY FAMILY ME. AND
OUR COMMUNITY. LIKE MANY OTHER
FAITH COMMUNITIES IN THE WEST
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY ACROSS THE
STATE. HAS TALKED IN RECENT
YEARS ABOUT HOW WE CAN. HELP TO
ADDRESS OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
WE'VE SEEN. A BIG INCREASE IN
THE WEST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEIR FAITH COMMUNITIES OF
EVERY DENOMINATION THAT WANT TO
LIVE OUT THEIR VALUES. NEVER
WANT TO BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
HERE. THEY WANT TO HELP OUR
HOMELESS FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS.
AND SO ONE OF THE IDEAS THAT
WAS PROPOSED. WAS BUILDING
SENIOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING ABOVE
OUR PARKING LOT. AS A WAY TO
HELP FOLKS IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND SO THE RABBI TALKS ABOUT
HIS VISION FOR BUILDING NOT.
ABOUT HOW WOULD ALLOW- KIDS
LIKE MINE. WHO ARE AT THE
PRESCHOOL THERE TO INTERACT
WITH FOLKS OF AN OLDER
GENERATION TO HELP KEEP.
SENIORS OFF THE STREETS WE SAW
IN THE MOST RECENT HOMES COUNT
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THAT.
FOLKS OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY TWO
ARE PARTICULARLY AT RISK FROM
HOMELESSNESS. SO THIS IS THE
KIND OF THING THAT I THINK CAN
REALLY BRING. BENEFITS TO OUR
TO OUR COMMUNITY. AND ALLOW
FAITH COMMUNITIES TO DO WHAT
THEY VIEW AS AN ESSENTIAL PART.
OF THEIR MISSION AND THEIR
WORK. AND I WILL JUST NOTE FOR
SOME OF THE CALLERS TO MENTION
THAT. YOU KNOW FOLKS IN
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE OPPOSED TO
THOSE FOLKS WHO LIVE NEAR THESE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS ACTION TO
REALLY. LIGHTNING CONVERSATION
THIS WEEKEND WITH SOME
CONSTITUENTS OF MINE WHO LIVE
ON GLORIA AVENUE NEEDS. NO
LITERALLY ARE. THE CORNER FROM
WHERE THE SENIOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHEN WE- LIT LITERALLY
WITH. HUNDREDS HUNDRED FEET
AWAY. AND THEIR THEIR YOUNG
FAMILY TO. TWO YOUNG DAUGHTERS.
AND SO I TALK TO THEM ABOUT
THIS PROJECT IN ABOUT THIS BILL
TO SEE WHAT THEIR REACTIONS
MIGHT BE. AND THEY WERE SO
ENTHUSIASTIC. THEY THEY THOUGHT
THAT THIS WAS BE A BEAUTIFUL
THING FOR OUR COMMUNITY. A
WONDERFUL THING AND REALLY
ENCOURAGED AND SO I THINK THAT.
THERE MAY BE. YOU KNOW COLORS
FROM AROUND THE STATE WHO WHO
ARE CALLING AND PURPORTING TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF. COMMUNITIES
ARE NEIGHBORHOODS. BUT THEY
ACTUALLY DON'T RELECT THE
MAJORITY OPINION IN. HIS
NEIGHBOR. SO I THINK THAT. WHY
THIS BILL SO. OUT OF THE- WITH.
WITH NINE. VOTES I KNOW WHETHER
SUCH POTS OF. ME DOWN. WERE
TOGETHER. REALLY HOPE YOU'RE ON
THE SAME PAGE WITH THE TRADES
AND I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS WANT
TO THOSE. CONVERSATIONS IN GOOD
FAITH BECAUSE THIS IS THE KIND
OF THING THAT I THINK WE CAN.
SEND HOPEFULLY TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK GET SIGNED
INTO. LAW TO DEMONSTRATE THE P.
ABOVE ALL FACE AND BACK. AND
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
WANT TO COME TOGETHER AND WANT
TO BE PART OF SOLVING OUR
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
I'M REALLY LOOKING FOR TO
FUNDING FOR THE BILL TODAY. AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
FORWARD. MR BONTA. THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER FOR ABOUT
BRINGING THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL FORWARD AYE I THINK IT'S
CERTAINLY CREATIVE- AND
INNOVATIVE AND THOUGHTFUL AND
ITS APPROACH AND- THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT IT PROVIDED
SOME OF ON LOCKING TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ABOUT THE STATE IS
INCREDIBLE IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
THAT WE TREAT. OUR WORKERS TO
BUILD OUR HOUSING- IN THE WAY
THAT THEY DESERVE I PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT AND I'M I'M THANKFUL
FOR YOUR ON GOING COMMITMENT TO
WORK WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
THAT DISCUSS YOU'VE HAD THE
ONES I KNOW YOU WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE TO TRY TO ARRIVE AT A
WHAT I HOPE WILL BE- A MUTUALLY
AGREEABLE SOLUTION ON ON THE-
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
COMPONENTS SO- I KNOW THAT'S
NOT EASY I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED
WITH THEM IN THE PAST
EXCESSIVELY ON VERY IMPORTANT
HOUSING BILLS WELL WITH YOUR
KNOWN TO OFF THEIR CHAMPION.
AND I HOPE YOU CAN A CALL IS
THAT IT IN HERE SO I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS I
PLAN TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
AKON IS THERE A MOTION WITH THE
BILL FOR. THE SECOND. GREAT I
JUST ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR HIS ENGAGEMENT WITH
OUR COMMITTEE AND FOR NOT
WORKING OUT- QUITE A FEW
MOMENTS FOR THIS BILL AND ALSO
WERE JUST ECHO ARE COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS ABOUT REPORTS OF THIS
IDEA OBVIOUSLY WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF THE MOST INTENSE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
INTERSTATES HISTORY BUT PART OF
WHAT I APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS
BILL. ARE THE FIVE PAGES OF
SUPPORT FROM THE FAITH
COMMUNITY- WHO VALUES ARE ABOUT
HELPING THOSE WHO ARE IN
INCREASE ANTICIPATED THIS TIME
AND APPRECIATE THE FAITH
COMMUNITIES KEEP PARTNERSHIP ON
HOUSING AND- WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BUILD A
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
THE BILL THAT HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH FAITH
LEADERS OVER THE YEARS ABOUT
HOW CHALLENGING IT IS BANNED
TO. WORK ON THEIR OWN
PROPERTIES TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT A MENTION TWO ASPECTS
OF THE BILL I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME DISCUSSION AROUND THE
HISTORIC PRESERVATION A MOMENT
THAT WAS ACCEPTED I UNDERSTAND
THE SENATE OF THE WORKING GROUP
ON THIS HAS A PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS COMMITTEE ALSO HAS A
PERSPECTIVE AND UP- THIS
COMMITTEE- WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS AMENDMENT- THE BILL WITH
THIS COMMENT SO I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT. WITH REGARD
THAT COMES WITH THE TWO THE OF
ALL OF OUR CALL SO APPRECIATE
THE- MANY CONVERSATIONS ARE
HAPPENING. BETWEEN THE AUTHOR.
AND STAKEHOLDERS THIS BILL AND
THE BUILDING TRADES I TINK WE
ALL WOULD. LIKE TO SEE A GOOD
RESOLUTION IN THIS BILL. OF
JUST REITERATE FOR THE PUBLIC.
THIS BILL WILL NEXT BE GOING TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. WHERE IT STILL CAN
BE AMENDED IN TIME FOR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS BILL-
BEFORE THE END OF SESSION SO.
WITH THAT TO LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT CONVERSATION AND HOPE IT
IS PRODUCTIVE. I'LL JUST
REITERATE. HI EVERYONE ON ALL
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE I KNOW-
HAVE THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
PUBLIC IN MIND AND- OUR HOPE IS
SET- WE CAN WORK THROUGH THESE
ISSUES AND- AND GET THERE. SO
WITH THAT. UNLESS ARE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS HELD HER BACK TO THE
SENATOR FOR HIS FINAL CLOSING
REMARKS. THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
COLLEAGUES EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR THOSE VERY THOUGHTFUL-
REMARKS AND THIS- AS A AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I GET REAL
MENTION THIS IS ONE OF THOSE.
IN MANY WAYS- SORT OF.MOM AND-
HI. I'VE KIND OF BILLS AT THE
NOT A THIRTY NOT NOTHING BUT
BILL ON THE SENATE FLOOR TO BE
NOTICED SOME OF THE SUPPORT
COMMENTS ARE SOME ORGANIZATIONS
THAT DON'T TYPICALLY SUPPORT
HIGH HOUSING BILLS THAT I
AUTHOR- THERE IS ENORMOUSLY
BROAD AND DEEP SUPPORT FOR THIS
APPROACH IT'S ONE OF THOSE
IDEAS AS THE CHAIR JUST MENTION
WHERE A LOT OF PEOPLE FOR A
LONG TIME OF AND SAYING WHY
AREN'T WE MAKING THIS EASIER
THIS BILL. WILL MAKE IT MUCH
MUCH EASIER- HIGH- YOU KNOW
ALTHOUGH I WILL TELL YOU THAT
YOU KNOW I THINK BY FOR ALL OF
US BUT PARTICULARLY FOR ME
GIVEN MY HISTORY OF THE TRADES
NEVER COMFORTABLE TO SIT HERE
AS YOU KNOW FOLKS I'VE ALWAYS-
VIEWS STRONG ALLIES ARE CLOSING
YOUR BILL- AS I MENTIONED WE
ARE. SIT DOWN THE COMMERCE ITH
A MISS HUNTER WE'RE GONNA COULD
OUR TO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
IN ALL. ALL PARTIES TO COME UP
WITH THE REST. IS COMP. WE HAVE
SPONSORS ON THIS BILL WHO HAVE
THEIR OWN OPINIONS- AND YOU
KNOW IT I VERY VERY VERY
COMPLICATED BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. THAT WE GET IT DONE
I THINK WE OWE IT TO THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA DO EVERYTHING WE CAN.
TO GET IT DONE SO WE'RE
BUILDING HOUSING. HAVING MIDDLE
CLASS- CONSTRUCTION WORKERS.
AND I TAKING THAT ALREADY
EXTREMELY ROBUST APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. AND MAKING IT EVEN
BIGGER. WE HAVE SUCH A NEED FOR
HOUSING WE WANT A LOT OF
CONSTRUCTION TO HAPPEN IN THE
STATE. OF HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EVERYTHING
ELSE AND WE DO THAT. BY
PARTNERING WITH THE HOUSE OF
LABOR SO COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ITEM.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TO OUR CHIU II
DEEP. GABRIEL GABRIEL I GLORIA
KILEY ILEY AYE MON. Là M<c.cyan></c>
NOT VOTING BONTA BONTA AYE
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA I
NINETY VALUE IN A VOTE SOME OF
IT OUT OF COMMITTEE WE WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WITH THAT YOU HAVE A
SECOND BILL 2% OF FALLEN FIVE
SB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT SENATE
OWNER. I THINK I CAN SAFELY
PROMISE OF THIS WILL BE A MUCH
OF THE BILL ARE GOING. HI SO I
COLLEAGUES SIZE SB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT- MAKES- CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND CLOSES LOOPHOLES-
AND HOUSING ELEMENT LAW.
RELATING TO TWO THINGS FIRST A
LONG STANDING HOUSING ELEMENT
LAW HAS REQUIRED. THAT WHEN A
CITY ADOPTS A HOUSING ELEMENT-
HAS TO DESIGNATE A ZONE IN THE
CITY. FOR BY RIGHT APPROVAL OF
HOMELESS SHELTERS- AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT AS WE
KNOW I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE
AND- LEFT WING SAN FRANCISCO OR
RIGHT WING. SOMEWHERE ELSE-
PEOPLE TEND TO PUSH BACK WHEN
YOU TRY TO PUT HOMELESS
SERVICES IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND WE HAVE A DEEP CRISIS NOT
JUST WITH HOMELESSNESS BUT WITH
ON SHELTERED HOMELESSNESS AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER. A MAJORITY
OF ALL I'M SHELTERED HOMELESS
IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. ARE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND THAT CREATES
MANY PROBLEMS THAT YOU'RE AWARE
OF WE NEED MORE SHELTER BEDS AS
WE TRANSITION PEOPLE. THE
PERMANENT HOUSING- SO WILL WE
SEE UNFORTUNATELY IS THAT SOME
CITIES. WHEN THEY DESIGNATE
THAT THAT BY RIGHT. HOMELESS
SHELTERS OWN THEY'LL PUT IT IN
THE FORMER. OUTLYING AREAS ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A REMOTE
DISCONNECTED INDUSTRIAL AREA.
WHERE THEY'LL PUT IT SOMEWHERE
WHERE IT'S PHYSICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO ACTUALLY CREATE A
HOMELESS SHELTER. THIS BILL
WILL POINT GUARD RAILS AROUND
THAT MAKE SURE. STILL LOCAL
CONTROL WERE WERE PUT ZONE BUT
ALL OF IT SOMEWHERE WORDS
ACTUAL CONNECT TRANSPORTATION.
YEAH I'M REASONABLY DISTANCE
THE THIRD. ACTIVELY
DRAMATICALLY THE WAY APPROVING-
A LEGALLY COMPLIANT HOUSING
ELEMENT- WHERE THEY CAN- HAVE A
TEMPORARY DEFICIENT HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT LASTS FOR QUITE
SOME TIME- INTO THE BILL WILL
CHANGE. OF THE INCENTIVES TO
ADOPTING. OUR TOPIC COMPLY
ELEMENT. SO COLLEAGUES EVERY I
YOUR ALL WILL WITH HERE TODAY.
HI IS BRIAN ACOSTA FROM
CALIFORNIA LEGAL ASSISTANCE. TO
THE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL ON BRAND ACOSTA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CAN HERE MISTER CHAIRMAN. YES I
CAN. BAGHDAD FUTURE MEMBERS
BRIAN GUST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
OUT OF THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
PROJECT SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE AND- WEEKLY ON BEHALF
OF OUR LOW INCOME CLIENTS WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO BE WORKINGWITH
MISTER WEINER ON THE SPELL TO
ADDRESS. THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS CRISIS THAT
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
IS KEENLY AWARE OF THE FIRST
STEP. IN THE COMPLEX PROCESS OF
DRAFTING A CRISIS IS FOR EVERY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAVE A
COMPLETE AND UP TO DATE LOCAL
PLANNED THERE HOUSING. WHICH IS
WHAT THIS BILL DEALS WITH THIS
BILL INSURER. A LOCAL GUY.
ADOPT THOSE IN A TIMELY MANNER
AND THAT THOSE PLANS ARE
COMPLETE AND COMPLY WITH. THE
LAW AND HAVE BEEN. APPROVED BY
THE STATE DEPARTMENT HOUSING
ANOTHER ONE SURE THAT THOSE
PLANS DO YOU ASISTIR WIENER
SAD. WE NEED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO DO WHICH IS TO PROVIDE REAL
SITES. THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE.
SHELTERS FOR OUR UNFORTUNATELY
GROWING HOMELESSNESS HOMELESS
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
TOGETHER. TO PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL WILL HELP MAKE THOSE PLANS
REAL AND HELP DELIVER ON OUR
PROMISE. TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
HOUSING AND SHELTER BUT THOSE
WHO NEED A MOUSE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE WOULD URGE NOT ABOUT.
IF I CAN AS MODERATOR TO OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOUNG MEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD.
OR OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
THAT'S ONE IN THEIR OWN NOW. IN
ONE MOMENT CHAIRMAN. MY ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LYING
TO NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD NINETY
NINE EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
DEVER CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE THREE SEVENTEEN THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS RICHARD WALKER
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
HOUSING AND HOME IN THE
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION IN OF
THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER IN ORANGE
COUNTY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AT. ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU BYE ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT THAT'S ONE ZERO.
LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN MY ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS ABOUT. BOB
NAYLOR- REPRESENTING FIELD SAID
IN COMPANIES. WE'RE INSPIRING
WE SUPPORT OF MERGING SHE
SHELTERS ON THIS BILL. LINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE ONE FOUR EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. UNABLE TO HEAR YOU IF
YOU'RE NOT IF IT BECAME MY ONE
FORTY EIGHT. AT THE TIME OF THE
TERM AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ME IF THERE ARE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT ARE. WHAT WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
OPPOSITION THE BILL THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION WITNESS. THE LADY
REGIMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT. ONE THAN THEIR OWN.
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. THE WOMAN WITH
THE CHAIR. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
IN HOUSTON. THANKS VERY MUCH
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION.
MISTER CURRY. SENATE YOU
MENTIONED THAT THAT UNDER THIS
BILL LOCAL COMMUNITIES WILL
STILL HAVE SOME DISCRETION AND-
WHERE. EMERGENCY SHELTERS ARE
CITED YOU KNOW AS FAR AS A IS
THAT MIGHT NOT BE A GOOD FIT
WOULD YOU MIND DESCRIBING JUST
BRIEFLY WHAT THAT WHAT THE
PARAMETERS OF THAT DISCRETION
ARE. I SURE- AND I'M SURE MR
ACOSTA MAYBE COULD JUMP IN AS
WELL I'M IT'S STILL VERY
STILL PUT IT CAN AND DOES IN AN
INDUSTRIAL AREA AS LONG AS THAT
IS THIRTY SEVEN AREAS WHERE
THERE ARE. GOING ON RIGHT SO
WE'RE NOT THERE AREN'T A LOT OF
CATEGORICAL RULES HERE- AND
EIGHT CD WITH WOULD LOOK AT A
AND THERE ARE SOME REALLY IT'S
WITH THIS IS REALLY ABOUT THE
MORE EXTREME EXIT POLLS RUN A
LITTLE A IT'LL BE LIKE. MILES
AWAY. OR ANYTHING IS HOW FOR NO
WOULD EVER ASK SITE A HOMELESS
SHELTER. AND NO ONE COULD GET
THEIR- AND SO THAT'S REALLY
WHAT IT. YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS
ABOUT- AND IT'S ALSO ABOUT YOU
KNOW NOT SAYING OKAY ARE THIS
IS OUR ZONE HERE AND THAT'S ON
HAPPENS TO BE. MADE ALL. I IN
TWENTY YEARS AT ALL YOU KNOW BE
REDEVELOPED BUT THERE'S NO WAY
TO ACTUALLY PUT IT RIGHTS OF
SOMETHING THAT IS ALREADY I'VE
EXISTING USE- THAT DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE GOING AWAY AND SO
IT. WOULD BE BUILT SO IT'S MORE
GENERAL PARAMETERS SO WHEN A CD
IS LOOKING TO MAKE SURE HOUSING
ELEMENT COMPLY BECOME BUT IT'S
GOING FLEXIBLE FOR CITIES FOR
OTHER PRODUCTS. DESCRIBE OKAY
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS. I WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS- IS
ONGOING WORK TO IMPROVE OUR
HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESSBASED
ON THE WORK WE'VE DONE THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS THIS NEXT SET OF
HOUSING ELEMENTS WILL FINALLY
PLAN FOR THE HOUSING THAT OUR
STATE DESPERATELY NEEDS. IT'S
IMPORTANT 104% TO COMPLETE THIS
NECESSARY PROCESS ON TIME.
WHILE ENSURING THAT CITIES
REALISTICALLY BUILD. OUR PLAN
FOR WHERE HOMELESS SHELTERS CAN
BE SIGHTED AND WITH THAT HAPPY
TO SUPPORT. WELCOME IS OUR
MOTION THIS FOR THEY'RE SECOND.
I WILL SECOND IT- LET'S TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE WITH THE MEMBERS
ARE HERE NOT A SECRETARY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TIãU. HI CHU I
DEEP GABRIEL GLORIA KILEY.
KILEY AYE LIAM ON BONTA QUIRK
SILVA. QUIRK SILVA I. WE WILL
WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD
ON THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. HI CENTER LEYVA.
HELLO HELLO. WE HAVE YOUR PER
FILE ITEM SIX SB NINE FIFTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THERE AND
MEMBERS SB NINE FIFTEEN WOULD
CREATE A PROTECTIVE PROCESS FOR
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN BY
PREVENTING THE MANAGEMENT OF
MOBILE HOME PARKS FROM
TERMINATING OR ATTEMPTING TO
TERMINATE TENDENCY OF AFFECTED
BILL OF AFFECTED RESIDENTS SB
NINE FIFTEEN IS NOT A RIP
FORGIVENESS BILL IT'S THE
PROVIDES WELL HOME RESIDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REAP A RICH.
WHAT CHANCE WE ARE AT IN WHICH
IT VERY CLEAR THAT THE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS CAN EXECUTE THEIR
AUTHORITY TO PROTECT THE PROP
PUBLIC. SORT HAVE LITERALLY RAN
OVER HERE. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT H. CD AS WELL AS
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS TO
ENFORCE AN EVICTION FOR HEALTH
AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS THAT
POTENTIAL HARM RESIDENTS OF THE
MOBILE HOME PARK MOBILE HOMES
ARE AFFORDABLE HOUSING ALTER
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
RELATIONS. THEY INCLUDE OUR
SENIORS VETERANS IMMIGRANTS AND
LOW OR FIXED INCOME INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES CURRENT LAW
DEFINES MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
AS BOTH HOMEOWNERS AND TENANTS
BECAUSE THE RESIDENTS OF THE
ACTUAL MOBILE HOME BUT THE PARK
OWNS THE LAND UNDERNEATH THE
MOBILE HOMES. ADDITIONAL
HOUSING MOBILE HOMES ARE UNDER
YOUR CIVIL CODE SECTION AND ARE
GOVERNED BY SPECIAL BODY OF LAW
KNOWN AS THE MOBILE HOME
RESIDENCY LOCK THE M. R. L. THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
BANNING OF ACTIONS WAS NOT
SPECIFIC. IS EMMA ARE EMERALD
CODE SECTIONS THE GOVERNMENT
WILL HOME PARK RESIDENTS AND
THE THREE DAY EVEN DAY AND
SIXTY DAYS BUT IT'S
REQUIREMENTS SICK THE TWO OF
ACTIONS. SB NINE AIMS TO
ADDRESS. DIFFICULT THE MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS AFFECTED BY
COVERT NINETEEN A GROUP YOUR
CHANCE TO REMAIN IN THEIR HOMES.
BASED IN SUPPORT AS BRUCE
CANTON. CORP COUNSEL. AND IF
SHOULD HOMEOWNERS LEE. AND BUT
WHAT CENTER. IF I COULD ASK
MODERATOR TO PLEASE ALLOW
MISTER STANTON TO TESTIFY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THIRD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M THREE
STANDARD CORPORATE COUNSEL FOR
KSMO WELL. THANK SUPPORT THE
BILL NINETEEN YEARS VETERANS
AND IMMIGRANTS LIVING IN MOBILE
HOMES OCCUPIED CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST STOCK. WELL HOUSING
WHEN THERE'S COOKING NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HIT. AND HAS BEEN
AGGRESSIVE I LIKE YOU WE
CLARIFY OR REITERATE ANY
POSSIBLE MISINFORMATION OR
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT THIS BILL.
FIRST IT'S NOT A HAND OUT FOR
FINANCIAL STIMULUS PACKAGE IF
WE PROVIDE HOMEOWNERS ON BLOW
OR FIXED INCOMES OF BIBLE
READING ROOM TO SEE THEIR WAY
OUT OF THIS ECONOMIC AND PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. IT PAINS NO
RECORD GIVE THIS IT ONLY ALLOWS
RESIDENT THE DIGITAL TIME TO
REPAY WRECKED THEY CANNOT PAY
DUE TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
HARDSHIP. RESIDENT SHALL REMAIN
LEGALLY OBLIGATED TO PAY ALL OF
THEIR RENT. SECOND IT FILLS
GAPS RELATED TO NOTICES
SPECIFIC TO MOBILE HOMES NOT
PREVIOUSLY ADDRESSED BY THE
GOVERNOR OR PRIOR ORDERS.
MOBILE RESIDENTS ARE GOVERNED
BY SPECIFIC CIVILCODE SECTIONS
OF THE BALLPARK RESIDENT THE
LAW IT DOES NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED TO PROTECT THEIR
HOMES THIS LEGISLATION. THAT
THIRD IT REPAYMENT OF DEFERRED
WRECKED CANNOT EXCEED ONE YEAR.
OR THE PARTIES COULD OTHERWISE
VOLUNTARILY AGREED TO A
DIFFERENT TIME PRESS. FINALLY
IT SPECIFICALLY DOES NOT IMPACT
THE ABILITY OF THE STATE OR ANY
LOCAL JURISDICTION TO ENFORCE
HEALTH AND SAFETY LAWS OR A
BETA DO SINCE. AND IT DOES NOT
IMPACT THE PARK OWNERS ABILITY
TO ADDRESS HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATIONS WHICH COULD CAUSE
YOU HARM. SIGNIFICANTLY THE
BILL BY IN ADDITION. ALL THE
APPLIES TO THOSE MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS DIRECTLY IMPACTED
MICHAEL THE NINETEEN. LIKE THE
MOBILE RESIDENTS THEMSELVES WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS MODEST
REASONABLE NOT AN OVER REACH
BUT IT'S A GUIDING LIGHT HELP
RESIDENTS ADVOCATE THIS
PANDEMIC STORM. AT FIND THEIR
WAY TO A SAFE HARBOR. YES OF A
WELL. ADVOCATING FOR HOMEOWNERS
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS STATE WHY FOR
THE LAST FIFTY FIVE YEARS ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO BE FOREIGN TO THE
MODERATOR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF LITIGATION
AND PRO BONO AT PUBLIC LAST
CENTER IN ORANGE COUNTY. WE ARE
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDES FREE CIVIL LEGAL
SERVICES FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS. WE WORK WITH MOBILE
HOME ON A ADVOCATE FOR THEIR
RIGHT. IT'S BEEN COMPANIES THAT
ENCOMPASSES A WIDE VARIETY OF
ISSUES. BUT REGULARLY INVOLVED
DISPUTE. WITH THE MOBILE HOME
PARK REGARDING RENT PAYMENT.
OUR CLIENTS CAN INDIVIDUAL.
THEIR MOBILE HOME A DOCTOR
THERE ONLY IN THAT. FOR MANY OF
THEM THE MOBILE HOME IS THE
MOST VALUABLE ASSET THEY WILL
EVER ON. OVER THE LAST FIVE.
DURING QUARANTINE. FIELD TO GET
THIRTY MORE OF OUR TENANT
WORRIED ABOUT HOW THEY WILL PAY
THEIR RENT. WONDERING WHAT
PROTECTION THERE MIGHT BE AND
WHAT TO DO IF THEY ARE UNABLE
TO EIGHT. WE ARE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR PUBLIC
PUBLIC TO CANADA. WHO ARE IN
NEED OF PROTECTION BECAUSE OF
THE POTENTIAL LOSS. AT THE PUMP.
WE HAVE HAD POINT COME TO IT
LET'S TALK ARTS MANAGEMENT. AND
YOU HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO COME TO
AN AGREEMENT. AND ARE NOW
WORRIED ABOUT ONLY LOSING THEIR
MOBILE HOME. BUT ALSO NOT
HAVING A PLACE TO GO DURING THE
TIME AND EVERYONE. IS BEING
ENCOURAGED BRING ALL. I'M GOING
TO STAND UP WITH. SB NINE
FIFTY. IT'S NOT REQUIRED BUT IT
MEANT. THAT PROVIDE MOBILE HOME
WHAT IS THE CHANCE FOR. THEIR
ASSET. AND THEIR HOME. DURING A
PANDEMIC. AND THEN PROVIDES THE
TALK TO GET BACK ON THEIR FEET.
TO REPAY ANY RENT THAT WOULD.
SB NINE FIFTY WHAT I'D
REASONABLE PROTECTION THE
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS. AROUND THE
STATE. AND WILL ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONNECTIVITY WILL REMOTE
IMPACTED REMAIN TOWN IN HELPING
DURING THE EPIDEMIC. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THE COURT AT NINE
FIFTEEN THANK YOU. ASK THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WE
TO SPEAK SO OF THIS BILL. TO
THE MODERATOR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO THEIR OWN
NOW. ONE MOMENT THE CHAIRMAN.
LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
ONE FORTY EIGHT ONE IS OPEN.
MAYBE YOU'RE ON MUTE. THE
CHAIRMAN THERE'S NO ONE I THINK
YOU. THANK YOU LET'S NOW GO TO
THE OPPOSITION I KNOW WE HAVE
HERE IN THIS ROOM INJURY
GOVERNOR- AND THEN IT'LL IT'LL
BE FOLLOWED BY JEEZ KNOCKER. MR
GOVERNOR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
ANSWER GOVERNOR BEHALF AT W. O.
MAY I RESPECTFULLY MUST OPPOSE
THE BILL- FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT STATEMENT
IN THE END I. THE BAY SO. WHY
ARE WE DEALING WITH THIS OP
GLOBAL ISSUE WITH ALL RENTERS
MOBILE HOME RENTERS ARE NO
DIFFERENT THAN APARTMENT
RENTERS RESIDENTIAL RENTERS.
EVERYBODY DESERVES THE SAME
PROTECTIONS AND WHY SHOULD WE
BE DISCUSSING THESE ISSUES
SEPARATELY AND THERE'S TWO BIG
REASONS WHY. THAT IT'S A
PROBLEM NO ONE ON THE AND
SAFETY ISSUE. WELL THE
FIREFIGHTERS LOCALLY MAY FEEL
LIKE SOME OF THE LANGUAGE OF
THE DRESS THEIR CONCERNS. EVERY
HEALTH AND SAFETY VIOLATIONS AT
A MOBILE HOME PARK OWNER YES BY
SHEER DEFINITION IS HELPING SAY
I HAVE A- THIS BILL BASICALLY
SET. PARK HONOR YOUR PICK AND
CHOOSE BETWEEN WHAT ONES WILL
BE A ONE YOUR FORGIVENESS AND
WHAT. AND SAFE TELL US WE WILL
TAKE. COURTS WE CAN ADJUDICATE
WHICH ONES ARE LIFE AND
THREATENED AND TELL US WHICH
ONES DESERVE A YEAR. BUT AS
WRITTEN WE HAVE TO TAKE EVERY
SINGLE HEALTH AND SAFETY
VIOLATION TO COURT AND THE
JUDGES WILL HAVE TO DECIDE
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T TAKE ONE
VIOLATION TO COURT. AND THAT
WAS AND SOMETHING. THAT WORKING
BE LIABLE. SO WE BELIEVE THAT
NEEDS TO BE FIXED WE BELIEVE
IT'S A CHIP WOULD BE REMOVED.
NUMBER TWO. THIS BILL SAYS NOT
ONLY DO WE HAVE TO. FOLLOW THE
RENT CHARGES PER YEAR AND-
LEVINSON LABELS RIGHT IT IS NOT
A FORGIVENESS. BUT THEY THEN TO
ADD ON UTILITY STATE CHARGES
LIKE STATE INSPECTION FEES.
WIRE MOBILE HOME PARK OWNERS
BEING ASKED IF YOU. ARE SIMPLY
THE BED. OF RIGHT OF COLLECT
RENT IN MAINE A PAR. IF WE
DON'T GET OUR RENT THAT'S ONE
THING. BUT NOT GETTING
UTILITIES AND STATE CHARGES
JUST ADDS INSULT TO INJURY. SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. TO THE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ALLOW
JASON OCCURRED TO TESTIFY. I NO
LONGER DARKER ON THE PHONE.
OKAY LET US MOVE AT THIS MOMENT
UNLESS MISTER REICHARDT COMES
BACK TO OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
TO WISH TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE FIFTEEN.
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. NINE
ONE ZERO FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE IN
MISTER BUT- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CREAM
GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. I AM TWO FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN TWO FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BECAUSE ROSS BUT THE ON
BEHALF OF SECURITY INVESTMENT
COMPANY- WE WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMON WMA AND WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AT THIS TIME THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD TO
ENSURE THAT ALL HOMEOWNERS TO
LOSE THEIR HOME DURING. THIS
COVERED CRISIS DUE TO ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT ARE
GENERALLY COMPLETELY OUT OF
THEIR CONTROL. AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT UNLIKE TRADITIONAL.
RESIDENTIAL RENTERS THESE
MOBILE HOMEOWNERS WHO MISTER
RENT PAYMENT. COULD STAND TO
LOSE NOT ONLY THEIR SHELTER BUT
THERE INVESTMENT IN THEIR HOME-
THE ONLY THING I'LL SAY IS I
WILL REITERATE- THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE HAD OUR COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS THAT IT'S- MY HOPE THAT
AS- A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT.
LEGISLATIVE MOVE FORWARD. TO
DEAL WITH THE COVERED- NINETEEN
IMPACT ON HOUSING. THAT THAT
THIS BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
AND I ASSUME THAT THIS WILL BE
PART OF THE BROADER
CONVERSATION. UP WITH THAT. A
LESSER ANY FINAL COMMENTS WILL
TURN BACK OVER TO THE CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OPPOSITION AND I DO HAVE SOME
DISAGREEMENTS FUNDAMENTALLY ON
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. NOT JUST.
SAY THAT- UTILITIES ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE A PASSED
THROUGH. BUT AS THE CHAIR OF
THE. HEY MISTER CHAIR YOU MADE
MY POINT FOR ME EXACTLY MOBILE
HOME OWNERS FACE SIGNIFICANT
LOSS WHEN THEY'RE EVICTED FROM
THEIR MOBILE HOME PARK. UNLIKE
APARTMENT TENANTS MOBILE HOME
OWNERS OWN THEIR HOME AND IS IT
LIKELY ARE SIGNIFICANT PART OF
THEIR NEST EGG. COUNTRY TO
POPULAR BELIEF MOBILE HOMES ARE
NOT EASILY MOBILE. SO IF
THEY'RE EVICTED THE RESIDENT
WOULD LOSE THEIR LARGEST ASSET
WHICH IN SOME CASES. PRESENTS
THEIR LIFE SAVINGS. TO THE
LANDLORD. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
COLLEGES ARE MOTION OF THIS
BEFORE BECAUSE MOTION AND IF
THERE'S A SECOND TWO IT MADAM
SECRETARY. PLEASE COLOR. DO YOU
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TWO FIVE
Q. I DEEP. DEEP NOT VOTING
GABRIEL. GLORIA KILEY. KILEY NO
LIMON. BONTA BONTA AYE AYE
QUIRK SILVA SIX OF AYE WE WILL
WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ENRON
THANK YOU SENATOR CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS WILL NOW GO TO FILE
AND SEVEN SB NINE NINE NINE
SENATOR ON BURKE.
WHENEVER
YOU'RE READING THIS YEAR PLEASE
ENTER SORRY THANK YOU OF MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THANK THE UP
TO THE PRESENT SB NINE NINE
NINE IN A PARTICULAR THANK YOU
TO YOUR STAFF MISTER CHAIR FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT IT IT'S
SIMPLY. RESOLVES A SITUATION
THAT IS BOTH ANOMALOUS AND
INEQUITABLE AS IT RELATES TO
MOBILE HOME PARK RESIDENTS SO
LET ME ILLUSTRATE HOW THIS.
WORKS RIGHT NOW UNDER EXISTING
LAW. YOU HAVE SAY TWO DIFFERENT
UNITS YOU'VE GOT A MOBILE HOME.
IN A HUNDRED METERS AWAY OF A
TWO MILLION DOLLAR HOUSE. IF
THERE'S A LOCAL RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCE AND THE MOBILE HOME
OWNER HAS A LEASE MORE THAN
TWELVE MONTHS WHICH IS QUITE
COMMON. AND THERE'S A RENT
CONTROL AN INSTANCE IN AFFECTED
THAT LOCALITY. THE TWO MILLION
DOLLAR. HOME TENANT. CAN AVAIL
HIMSELF OR HERSELF OF THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE LOCAL RENT
CONTROL ORDINANCE WHERE IS THE
PERSON LIVES IN THE SENIOR PARK
A HUNDRED METERS AWAY HAS NO
SUCH PROTECTIONS. AND THIS IS
THE RESULT. OF WHAT WHAT I
WOULD CHARACTERIZE AS AN
ANOMALY IN THE LAW. THAT SAYS
THAT IF YOU ARE IN A MOBILE
HOME PARK AND YOU HAVE A LEAST
ONE IN TWELVE MONTHS. YOU CAN'T
AVAIL YOURSELF OF THE
PROTECTIONS OF ANY RENT
STABILIZATION A RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCE. IN THE AREA. AND SO
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS SIMPLY
SAYS LOOK AT. ARE THE LAW WILL
BE APPLIED EQUALLY. IT MEANS
THAT THE LOCALITY THEN CONTROLS
WHETHER OR NOT GOING TO BE RENT
STABILIZATION FOR CONTROL. NOT
IMPOSE STATEWIDE RENT CONTROL
ARM AND THAT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE
IS THE BENEFITS OF THAT BUT
WHAT IT DOES DO IS IT RETURNS
TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY THE
ABILITY TO MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION. NOW WHILE THE
OPPONENTS ARE GONNA TESTIFY
THAT THIS BILL SOMEHOW.
ELIMINATES LONG TERM LEASES
THEN I WOULD INVITE THE
COMMITTEE TO ASK THE QUESTION
WHERE IN THE BILL DOES IT.
ELIMINATE TERM LEASES IT DOES
NOT IN IN FACT IF THERE'S AN
ISSUE IF THERE IS A CONCERN IF
THERE IS ABOUT WILL BE HAPPY TO
AMEND THE BILL TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT DOESN'T PRECLUDE LONG
TERM LEASES. NOW WHAT IT DOES
DO IS THAT. IF THERE IS A LONG
TERM LEASE. AND RENT CONTROL
COMES IN BEING IN THAT LOCALITY.
THEN THEY CAN AVAIL THEMSELVES
OF THAT PROTECTION IT ALSO
GRANDFATHERS IN LONG TERM
LEASES. UP THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE SO IN THE EXAMPLE I
GAVE AT THE OUTSET IF YOU'RE IN
A MOBILE HOME PARK AND YOU'VE
GOT A LONG TERM LEASE THAT
YOU'VE SIGNED BEFORE THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL.
YOU'RE GONNA BE BOUND BY THE-
AGAIN IT DOESN'T PRECLUDE LONG
TERM LEASES NOW. IF YOU'VE GOT
A LONG TERM LEASE THAT SAY FOR
EXAMPLE. THE 20% ANNUAL. ARE
INCREASE OR FROM IN. THEN IF UP.
IF THERE'S PASSAGE OF A LOCAL
RENT CONTROL ORDINANCE YES THAT
20% MAY BE REDUCED TO WHATEVER
THE- A PROVISIONS ARE OF LOCAL
ORDINANCE IT'S SIMPLY AGAIN A
MATTER OF EQUITY. IN A MATTER
OF REMOVING THIS AMOUNT IN
STATE LAW. I WOULD URGE ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU LET'S GO TO YOUR
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT- LET'S
FIRST GO TO LINDA NINE. HI MY
NAME IS LINDA PRESIDENT OF THE
AT THE LOWER IN COURT AGAINST
HE NINE NINETEEN. FOR NOTHING
IN IT WELL FOR THE MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS AND PARKS CORNER
MEMORY INTO. BUT THEY'RE ONLY
CHIU CLOTHING NOT YEAR LEASE AT.
SECOND EVERYTHING IN THE BILL
PROVIDES LOW GOT. WHAT THEY
NEED TO LOCAL COULD. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT DID YOU WHAT THEY
CAN'T FOR SENIOR VETERANS AND
IMMIGRANTS LIKE. AND THEY DO
WHAT THEY SAY IT MEANS NOTHING.
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS LEASE THE
LAND UNDERNEATH THE HOME OF THE
WEOWN. HOWEVER A MOBILE HOME
LATE THAT A TWELVE MONTH PLUS
ONE DAY IS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN YOUR FLIGHT THAT.
GETTING PERFECT OF LOCAL LAW OR
NOT ALLOWS TO HAPPEN. THIS BILL
A LOT OF LOCAL OR DID YOU NEED
SOMETHING THIS BILL PROTECT
RIGHT AND READ THE CON. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. LET'S NOT GO
TO JOEL AYALA. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CHILE YALLA CHIEF OF
STAFF WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
BUSINESS AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PROUD BECAUSE BONTA
IS THE SB NINE NINE NINE I LIKE
FIRST THANK A SENATOR I'M FOR
BRING FORTH THIS MATTER. THE
MEASURE BEFORE YOU DO SEEKS TO
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
ANOTHER TOOL TO ADDRESS THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS AS
MENTIONED ON THE PRIOR BILL
WELL HOME RESIDENTS INCLUDE
FIXED INCOME SENIORS DISABLED
INDIVIDUAL VETERANS AND
IMMIGRANT GROUPS THAT ARE OFTEN
VULNERABLE LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS. STATE LAW CURRENTLY
PREVENTS ANY MOBILE HOME
RESIDENT WITH AT LEAST UNDER
THE WAY HERE FROM RECEIVING.
LOCAL RENT WHEN THEY XIN IN
FACT AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE
PROTECTIONS ESTABLISHED UNDER
OUR LOCAL ORDINANCE ARE ONLY
AVAILABLE TO APPROXIMATELY 60%
OF THOSE IN THE COUNTY SERVICE
AREA DUE TO CURRENT
RESTRICTIONS. ACCORDING TO THE-
QUALIFY LONG TERM AGREEMENT ANY
MODERATOR THIS ONE. THERE THERE
IS A MODERATE ALIGN. HELLO
MYSTERY YOU MAY CONTINUE. OKAY
ALL RIGHT I LOCAL ORDINANCES
NOT PRECLUDED ALL BY LONG TERM
AGREEMENT IN THE DOES THIS
BILL- PARK OWNERS IN RESIDENTS
COULD CONTINUE TO KEEP LAW
EXISTING LONG TERM LEASES AS
WELL THE CENTER TO NO ONE'S
INCLUDING TERMS FOR MINIMUM
RENT INCREASES. ALTHOUGH NOT
REQUIRED IN THE OR OF A LOCAL
STABLES ORDER THOSE DECISION
REMAIN. THAT THE DISCRETION OF
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. WHAT
THE BILL DOES DO IS PROVIDE
STABILITY AND CERTAINTY FOR
VULNERABLE MOBILE HOME
RESIDENTS BY AFFORDING THEM
PEOPLE PROTECTIONS ENJOYED BY
RESIDENTS OF APARTMENTS AND
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES. AGAINST
UNANTICIPATED AND- RENT
INCREASES. ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE RESPECTFULLY.
WE ALL. WELL WE'VE SENIOR
POLICY AND DANIELLE BE DEPUTY
COUNTY COUNSEL TO HELP ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. TO MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT WISH TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE NINE NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE NINE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE IN THEIR OWN NOW. IN
ONE MOMENT THE CHAIRMAN. LINE
THREE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS RICHARD WALKER SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY OF THE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION UNIT OF
THE PUBLIC OFTN IN ORANGE
COUNTY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THAT THE NINE NINE NINE. ANY
OTHER MEMBERS THE PUBLIC. ONE
MOMENT IF THE CHAIR ONCE AGAIN
AT THE ONE IN ZERO TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE NINE.
WE'RE JUST TAKING THE NUMBER
NOW THERE. ONE MOMENT. LINE
NUMBER THREE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SMOKE BYNUM ON BEHALF
OF UNITED MAGIC WORKERS ASKED
ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY
STRONG SUPPORTER THAT THOUGH
THANK YOU. AND AT THE TIME OF
THE CHAIRMAN THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE. THANK YOU KNOW LET'S GO
TO WITNESSES FOR THE
OPPOSITION- TESTIFYING BY PHONE
JASON OCCURRED. HI MISTER
GOVERNOR TEST FINALLY HAVE THE
OPPOSITION OKAY. ACTUALLY IS
YOUR MICROPHONE ON A JUST WANT
TO DOUBLE CHECK. YEAH I AS WAS
IN MY- YEAH YES OKAY I HAVE TO
GO TO A MAP OF WMA LET'S
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB NINE
NINE NINE- SENATOR UMBERG IS
CORRECT BILL DOES NOT AND THE
PRACTICE OF LONG TERM LEASES
THIS BILL WHAT AND THE PRACTICE
OF LONG TERM LEASES IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT MAKE IT EASY
CONTROL. EGYPTIAN THIS WILL
LEAD TO READ INCREASES FOR
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS IN THE STATE BECAUSE
IT AT THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THE RESTAURANT AND IF YOU
BELIEVE THAT YOU CAN IN A
CONTRACT IT MEANS THAT EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOUR DESERVE
SENATOR CHU WHO DOES NOT HAVE
ANY MOBILE HOME PARKS AND REC.
YOU OFFER THIS IS IN YOUR
DISTRICT WAS FIRED ALTHOUGH
SIMPLY DELIVER BACK TO THE
LOCAL CONTROL SO FRIENDLY THE
MAFIA. THEY HAVE A RENT CONTROL
3% WE HAVE SHOWN WE HAVE SHOWN
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE CPR
COURSE 1% CONTRACT FOR FIVE TEN
FIFTEEN OR TWENTY YEARS UNDER
THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- OF MINE OF FIVE IF
THIS BILL GOES THROUGH. ACOSTA
RIGHT LEASES THAT. WILL BE A 3%
REVENUE RIGHT NOW IN CPR WHICH
1% MANTRA. WHY WOULD YOU WANT
TO THREE FOR ABOUT WHAT EXPECT
CONTROL. AND IF YOU GET FOR THE
PLUMBING CPR PLUS 1% FOR THE
THIRD. YEAR THAT DOESN'T THAT I
HOME ON A FEW DO AND ENJOY. THE
DEACONS BOX THAT PERSON TURNS
SO. AND THEN THE NEXT RESIDENT%
CAN TO GO SHE A LOWER. THIS LAW
WAS ENACTED IN EIGHTY WITH A
LEROY GREEN. AFTER BECAUSE
OWNERS WOULD NEGOTIATE A LOWER
RENDON RECORDS JURIST THAT WAS.
SO THEY TRY TO FIND A BALANCE
THEY WANT TO GIVE RIGHT LONG
TERM THE LADY AND YOUR BILL. TO
GO SHE BOTH LOW THEY'RE BOTH
RENT CONTROL AND THEN. TO HAVE
A LONG TERM. YOU CAPITAL. AND
THEN WHEN WE TURNED OVER THE
YOUR FLIGHT. INCREASE AND THEN
THE NEXT RED. BECAUSE YOU IF
THIS BILL. IT WILL SIMPLY MEAN
OWNERS AND VACANT COUNTRY
JURIST. WILL BE ONLINE TO MONTH.
AND ONE YEAR. REVERT BACK TO
NINETEEN FIVE. AND THE DOESN'T
HELP. WE JUST. YOUR VISION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LET ME
ASK OUR THE MODERATE OF THEIR
OTHER MY OF THE PUBLIC THEY
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
YES. SORRY MR CHAIRMAN JAMES
MICHAEL BATTLE CAN GIVE OVER
ROPES AND SNAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILE HOME PARK
OWNERS ALLIANCE FIRST LET ME
START BY APOLOGISING MISTRIAL
ON I DID NOT MEAN TO INTERRUPT
HIM A MOMENT AGO HE WAS
TESTIFYING AND THE REASON
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY ON THE
LAST BILL I WAS JUST TRYING TO
CONFIRM THAT YOU WANT COULD
HEAR ME SO MY APOLOGIES. NINE
NINE EIGHT GOING TO ECHO THE
CALM MADE BY. GOT AND I WILL.
THEM BUT I WILL SAY YOU KNOW
THERE ARE MANY REASONS. EXAM OF.
LONG TERM LEASE. ACTUALLY
AFFORD RATHER THAN. LEFT AND
THEN A EIGHT IN LOCAL RENT
CONTROL. IT'S WHAT WOULD GIVE
THEM AND SO YOU KNOW ONLY.
THESE BECAUSE- MISTER GOVERNOR
STATED OUR- INAPPROPRIATE. I
DON'T THINK IT YOU KNOW IN
LIMITING THE PERSONAL ALL
REMAINING. WORK PROTECTION. ACT
ALLOW. THE RESIDENT THE ABILITY
TO. GO SHAPE WITH THE LANDLORD.
ALL THOSE BETTER TERMS. AGAIN
YOU KNOW AND I LOOK LOOKS
ALMOST BUT I THINK IT'S- REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE COMMITTEE.
STAND IT. YOU WERE RIGHT. UNDER
THIS NOT HAPPENING RIGHT. RIGHT
SHIPPED. OUT A LONG TERM LEASE
THAT IS OFFERED SPEND BY UP
PARK. MANAGED MANAGEMENT WHEN
THEY THE LEAST HALF TO PROPOSED
THEM IN RIGHT. A SEPARATE.
EXPLAINING THE TO DO SO. IT
SHOULD CHURCH IT THEY HAVE THE
AT. TO ASSURE TERM. TWELVE
MONTHS LEFT UNDER THE SAME
REGION CHAU SO LINE. PARK
MANAGE IS NOW NOT TO DO TO
THREATEN ARRAY. WITH THE HIGHER
RENTAL AND NOT MESSAGES TO
WORKING TO ON. TO SO FOR
ENTRIES IN. READ BY MISTER WILL.
QUESTION VOTE ON THE BILL.
THANK LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THAT THE-
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. IF YOU TO
SPEAK ENOUGH. OF SB NINE NINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE. ZERO ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE NINE
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE'LL. IN LINE ONE ZERO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE ONE FOR THE LINE IS
OPEN. LINE. TWO FIFTY TWO FIVE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TO
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS ROSS
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF THE SECURE
SECURITY INVESTMENT COMPANY
AGAIN WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF WMA AS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
NINE ONE OH FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBERS CREAM
GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND THE CHAIR AT THIS TIME
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION.
SAID I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR TO ADDRESS-
THE CHALLENGES THAT I KNOW.
ABOUT FOLKS HAVE HAD AROUND THE
CIRCUMVENTION OF LOCAL RENT
CONTROL ORDINANCES BY USING
MULTI YEAR LEASES. ARE WE ALL
KNOW THE LEGISLATURE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CAREFULLY
CONSIDER THE STATE'S ROLE AND
HOW- WE MAY IMPACT LOCAL RENT
STABILITY POLICIES. IN THIS
YEAR DOES SEEM IT IN THIS CASE
IT DOES SEEM THAT THE- MULTI
YEAR LEASE EXEMPTION HAS
APPEARED TO BE A BARRIER. OFFER
SOME LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
ARE SEEKING TO PROTECT THE FOR
ABILITY SO WITH THAT. I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LET ME JUST ADDRESS
SEVERAL CONCERNS THE RACE-
FIRST. OKAY THREE CAN FOR
EXAMPLE IF. A RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCE CANDACE GLUED MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS THAT ORDINANCE
CAN SPECIFICALLY SAY WE WILL
ONLY PROVIDE PROTECTION TO
THOSE AND STICK BUILT HOUSING.
WE WILL EXCLUDE THOSE IN MOBILE
HOME PARKS THAT. THIS BILL DOES
NOT PRECLUDE THAT NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO IN TERMS OF VACANCY
CONTROL OR D. CONTROL. THE BILL
DOES NOT SPEAK TO THAT ISSUE. A
LOCALITY CAN IN ENACTING ITS
ORDINANCE OR MODIFYING ITS
ORDINANCE. ARE ENACT A
PROVISION THAT YOU'D PROVIDES
FOR VACANCY CONTROL OR VACANCY
DEEP CONTROL IT'S LEFT UP TO
THE LOCALITY- IT DOES NOT
ELIMINATE ANY PROTECTIONS THE
BILL IS. URGE MEMBERS ACTUALLY
LOOK AT WHAT THIS BILL DOES
THERE ARE. TO SEE. WE ARE TO LA
THE IN IN THE ANOMALY IS I
MENTIONED EARLIER IN STATE.
THAT PREVENTS THOSE IN MOBILE
HOMES FROM BEING PROTECTED- IF
THERE'S A RENT CONTROL
ORDINANCE THAT'S AN EFFECT WITH
THAT ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES IS OUR MOTION OF
THIS FOR. AS OUR SECOND. A
SECOND. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MAN AMENDED Q. HI CHU
I DEEP. DEEP NOT VOTING GABRIEL.
ZERO NOT VOTING GLORIA KILEY
KILEY NO LIMON BONTA BONTA AYE
QUIRK SILVA OKAY QUIRK SILVA
NOT VOTING. WE'LL KEEP THIS
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU SIR. LET'S PROCEED TO FILE
ITEM NINE SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YES BE TEN EIGHTY FIVE. ITS
PURPOSE IS TO HELP IMPROVE THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW THAT THE
STATE HAS SO THERE WE ACTUALLY
GET MORE UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT A LAW THAT
WAS PASSED IN I BELIEVE
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. TO
BASICALLY INCENTIVIZE. BUILDERS
OF MARKET RATE UNITS TO INCLUDE
IN THEIR PROJECTS AFFORDABLE
UNITS BUT WHAT WE FOUND IS IN
ALL THE TIME THAT WE HAD THAT
ONE PLACE. LESS THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HAVE APPROVED A PROJECT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE DENSITY BONUS.
SO SPECIFICALLY WHAT SB TEN
EIGHTY FIVE DOES IS IMPROVES
THE ABILITY FOR DENSITY BONUS
TO BE USED FOR STUDENT HOUSING.
STUDENT HOUSING IS CONFIGURED
DIFFERENTLY THAN REGULAR
HOUSING SO THE PARTICULAR-
COMPONENTS IN. THIS BILL. HELP
MAKE SURE THAT IT COMPLY TO
STUDENT HOUSING. IT CONFORMS
ARE DENSELY BONUS LOCKED WITH
REQUIREMENTS IN OUR HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. IT DADS A-
PARKING WAIVER FOR PROJECTS
THAT ARE FOR SALE UNITS WITH A
MINIMUM OF 40% MODERATE INCOME
AND ARE WITHIN A HALF A MILE
TRANSIT. AND ELIMINATES THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IMPACT FEE
JUST THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IMPACT FEES ON ONLY THE
AFFORDABLE IN THE BONUS UNITS
NOT ON ANY OTHER UNITS. SO LET
ME TALK QUICKLY ABOUT THE FEE
PORTION AND IREALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS BECAUSE
IT GAVE A GOOD X. A GOOD
EXPLANATION OF THAT. THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF THE DENSITY BONUS
LAW IS TO INCENTIVIZE THE
BUILDER. TO INCLUDE AFFORDABLE
UNITS UNDER AND HOW IT DOES IT
IS BY GIVING THEM SOME BONUS
SOME MORE UNITS THAN THEIR THE
ZONING WOULD ALLOW. CHARGING
THE FEED THE AFFORDABLE FEE ON
THOSE BONUS UNITS IS COUNTER TO
THE PURPOSE BECAUSE- THE THOSE
UNITS ARE WHAT. HELP COVER THE
COSTS OF THE AFFORDABLE UNITS
THAT ARE INCLUDED IN THE
PROJECT DUE TO THE DENSITY
BONUS. IT'S SORT OF TECHNICALLY
DOUBLE DIPPING. AND SO WHAT CAN
EIGHTY FIVE DOES IS HELP US GET
IN CONFORMITY WITH A COURT
RULING TO LEARN A COURT
DECISION WHICH BASICALLY SAID
THAT. THE LOCAL ORDINANCES USE
OF THAT FEE ON THOSE TWO UNITS
WAS COUNTRY AND THERE ARE
TURNING GENERAL'S RECENT
OPINION WHICH IS CITED IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT EXPRESS THAT.
IMPOSING FEES ON UNITS IS
CONTRADICTORY TO STATE LAW SO
IT THIS SO I JUST WANNA BE
SOME CONFUSION THAT THE BILL
DOES NOT ELIMINATE FEES LIKE IF
THERE'S A STRUCTURE FEES OR
OTHER TYPES OF THE SCHOOL FEES.
FEES IN THOSE THINGS IT DOES
NOT TOUCH THOSE AND IT ONLY
AFFECTS THE FEE ON THE BONUS
UNITS THAT IS A FEE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT IS ALL
ALL I THINK THERE'S BEEN SOME
CONFUSION SO I JUST WANT TO
RAISE THAT. THERE'S A FEW
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE RAISED
THE ISSUE NOT- ARMED MEN BUT
SAM AND I WANTED TO BE A VERY
CLEAR AND FINALLY THIS BILL I
FEEL IS VERY MEANT THREE TO A.
B. TWO THREE FORTY FIVE. ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ THIS
BILL WHICH IS INCREASES THE
PERCENT OF LOW INCOME UNITS AND
LOW INCOME IN ITS THE YOU CAN.
GET USING THE DENSE PRESS AND I
SUPPORT THAT AND WITH THAT I'LL
HAVE MY WITNESS I HAD A KEY
WITNESS WHO UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE THE CHANGING DATES WAS
NOT ABLE TO JOIN US BUT THAT SO
I HAVE ANOTHER- I BELIEVE IT
IS- DIRECTION. FROM TURNERS. IF
I COULD ASK MISTER GROSS FROM
THE CENTER TO TEST. A GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR- MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE UP EXACTLY BEEN
METCALF ON BEHALF OF THE TURNER
CENTER FOR HOUSING INNOVATION
AT UC BERKELEY WHERE I AM NOW
THE MANAGING DIRECTOR. OF THE
CAN TODAY TO- DISCUSS BRIEFLY
THE TURNER CENTERS RESEARCH ON
THE STATE THAT THE BONUS LAW.
AND WHY CHANGE THIS LAW- ARE SO
DESPERATELY NEEDED TO LIMITS
GIVE A VERY BRIEF BIT OF
BACKGROUND. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN-
SPARATE THE CARE CENTER
RELEASED THE RESULTS FROM ITS
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTIAL LAND USE
SURVEY WHICH- SURVEYED TURNER
FIFTY CITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE REPRESENTING THE LARGE
MAJORITY OF THE POPULATION-
ECHOING CENTER SCANNERS-
STATEMENT EARLIER ONE OF OUR
FINDINGS FROM THIS RESEARCH FOR
THAT THAT THAT THAT THE BONUS
BALL BY ISRAELI USED. FROM
TWENTY. TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONLY
FIVE. OF TWENTY JURISDICTIONS
HAD ANY DEVELOPMENT THE
UTILIZED THAT'S THE BONUS- AND
MOST OF THESE PLACES THAT HAD
USED THAT HAD YOU TO PERHAPS
ONLY ONCE OR TWICE- IN FACT
ONLY 14% OF THE RESPONDENTS ARE
STUDY HAD EVER USED IT FOR
THREE OR MORE PROJECTS. ALL
THIS TELLS US THAT THE STATE
THAT THE BONUS WILD VERY WELL
CONCEIVED A VERY IMPORTANT- THE
DESTRUCTION TODAY DOES NOT
WORK. SO THE WORK AS WELL THE
COULD. IDEALLY MORE PROJECTS
THAT WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE SENSIBLE IN THE FALL
LEADING TO THE- PREFERRED
OUTCOME OF MORE. RESTRICTIVE
AFFORDABLE UNITS AS WELL AS WE
MORE HOUSING PLIGHT FOR ALL SO
FORCES WELL ARE ARE BADLY DO
IT. AND THAT HE BONUS. REPORTER
WHENEVER ROBERT HOUSING. I JUST
A FEW WEEKS THE TWO CENTER
RELEASED POLICY. THAT GAMMA.
THE BECAUSE BOTH BY THIS BILL
AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. AND OUR ANALYSIS
INDICATES- THAT THESE-
REVISIONS TO ST LAW PROPOSED. I
WOULD MAKE THAT THE BOTH LAW
MUCH MORE LIKELY TO WORK IN
MANY MORE GEOGRAPHIES AND FOR
MANY MORE PROJECTS- WHICH IS
WHY- WE AT. THE OUR SUPPORT OF
BOTH OF THESE- BUILT BY THE
THIRTY FIVE AND ITS COUNTERPART
ASSEMBLY BY HAVING A BURKE AND
DOLLARS THANK YOU. MISS TOUR
MAYBE BEFORE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES I MUST APOLOGIZE I
DID NOT STATE AT THE BEGINNING
WHICH I SHOULD OF THAT I AM
ACCEPTING. ALL THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS. WHICH ARE THE RINK
FULLY REMOVES THE BONUS FOR
MODERN MODERATE INCOME RENTAL
UNITS. AND VARIOUS THINGS THAT
HELP WITH AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE THERE IS ONE A PORTION I
THINK IN THE ANALYSIS THAT-
EVEN THE COMMITTEE HAS
WITHDRAWN- IN TERMS OF AN
AMENDMENT IT WAS SOMETHING THAT
WOULD HAVE- WHAT IT WHATEVER
FACT I AM ACCEPTING THE ONES
THAT YOU HAVE. ASKED FOR AND TO
LET ME DO SO AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THOSE AMENDMENTS
HAVE REMOVED THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN A NUMBER
OF OTHER GROUPS OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. LET'S PROCEED NOW TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TO THE MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND ANYONE
WHO SUPPORTED THE BILL PLEASE
LIST YOUR NAME. AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE ZERO
EIGHT FIVE. PRESS ONE IN THEIR
OWN NOW. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB CAN
EIGHTY FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
IN THEIR OWN NOW. LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING IF THE
COURT THANK YOU. NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU-
GOOD AFTERNOON DEBRA CARLTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. LINE
FOR THEIR OWN NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CAN DOWN ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. LINE FOR
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE A
CRANK ON BEHALF OF THE LOOK ON
VALLEY AT HOME SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS EVEN STRONGER WITH
THE BAY AREA HOW THE AT THE
COALITION AND THE COURT AT THE
TEN EIGHTY FIVE THANK. LINE.
FOR THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ADAM REGULARLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THE PORT THANK YOU. AND ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE STRUCTURE
MEMBERS THIS IS BOB NAYLOR.
REPRESENTING PEOPLE SAID IN
COMPANY A AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS WHICH STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THIS IN ADDITIONAL
CREATIVE HOUSING TELEVISED
SKINNER. LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER
MODEL THAT WAY HOLD PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THREE PEOPLE ASH AND A PLAN
FOUNDATION AND CAME TO THE
PARTNER TO PARK. AS WELL
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY. HABITAT
THANK YOU. THANK SO YOU CAN
HELP. AND HER. ALL THANK YOU.
NINE TWO THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. KEVIN
ANDERSON ON THE HAPLESS SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MINE THREE
EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IS HUNTER ON
OF SCHNEIDER NORTON IN SUPPORT.
MORNING TO SEVENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS SANDY GEORGE FOR THEAMERICAN PLAYING ASSOCIATION IN
FULL SUPPORT AS AMENDED THANK
YOU. NINE TWO OH SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
YOUR TEACHER MEMBERS MICHAEL
GUNNING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AT LEAST THE EVENTUAL
ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. ONE FOUR OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE FOUR ZERO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON ON A LAWLER AT THE
TOP OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION-
CONFIRMING THAT WE HAVE WITH
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
APPRECIATE THE TENDER WORKING
SO HARD TO RESOLVE ARE
CONCERNED. NINE ONE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS WILL BE ABLE TO OUR IN
BEHALF OF FACEBOOK AND SUPPORT.
AT THE TIME OF THE GERMAN
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE IT TO-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO OPPOSE THE BILL. IF WE COULD
OPEN UP THE LINES ARE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN PPOSITION OF SB TEN
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. IN ONE MOMENT THE
CHAIR. I WON FIFTY SIX THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
ONE FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS ONE ACT OF MCELROY OF.
GRAY BROWN AVENUE BLOCK CLUB
AND THE NORTHERN. LAST PORTION
OF THEM PARKING GOT FUTURE
LAFAYETTE WE UPHOLD THIS BILL
VERY MUCH DAMAGE ARE BEAUTIFUL.
I CAN EXPECT HER LINE FOR OKAY
THANKS YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE FOR ALL SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE CHARACTER BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF PASADENA AND
WHILE WE ARE APPRECIATIVE OF
THE MOMENT THAT WE'RE TAKING
STATE COMMITTEE WE STILL REMAIN
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EILEEN BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOOD IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SIXTY FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M FOR
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS
RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION- WE
APPRECIATE THE A MEMBERS OF THE
CENTER'S TAKEN TODAY AND WITH
THAT WE REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KAREN OBEYED I REPRESENT GRAY
LINE AT NEIGHBORHOODS- FOR
QUALITY OF LIFE WE ARE UP IN
PETALUMA CALIFORNIA. AND MY
COMMENTS TODAY ARE REGARDING-
WHAT LOOKS GOOD ON PAPER. ISN'T
ALWAYS DOESN'T ALWAYS TRANSLATE
TO WHAT WERE ON THE GO. WE ARE.
ONE FOR OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
ANASTASI OF ANNAPOLIS FRANCISCO
TENANTS IN SAN FRANCISCO BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO OPPOSE THAT TEN
EIGHTY FIVE ON SEVEN SIXTEEN IN
RECOGNITION OF SAN FRANCISCO'S
LOCAL PLANNING AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TOOLS. THAT WILL RESULT
IN A REJECT. NINE FOUR ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE VOICE OF WARREN A
LIFETIME CALIFORNIAN ON BEHALF
OF HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
ONE ZERO EIGHT FIVE. NINE FOUR
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HI BOBBY LOPEZ
FROM BILL THE PORTABLE FASTER
CALIFORNIANS STRONG OPPOSITION-
THIS WILL RESULT IN FORTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS UNLOCKED
AFFORDABLE HOW THE IMPACT
FUTURE THING PROJECT. LINE.
THREE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANTED
TO REMIND FOLKS DURING THIS.
DURING THIS COMMENT PERIOD- DE
UP MEMBERS THE OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT YOU SHOULD LIST YOUR
NAME. AND YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
THAT IS HOW WE CONDUCT PUBLIC
COMMENT DURING THIS PERIOD OF
THE TESTIMONY THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PAT.
TAYLOR I'M THE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM OF THE WEST TO LOOK LIKE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB ONE ZERO
EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLOTO OUR
I'M OPPOSED. I AM FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS CLARK ON ALONG
READ OF MOUNT VIEW HIGH SCHOOL
OPPOSE THE BILL. I WON FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M PAMELA GIVER MEN
PRESIDENT NORTHEAST SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY ACTIVIST WE ARE
OPPOSED TO SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE
WHICH TAKES AWAY OUR. ONE ONE
OH THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS SUSAN
WINBERG FROM THE FRANKLIN
CORDER COALITION WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. LINE FOR FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIND FOUR ONE FIVE IN
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS RECALL
PRISON APPLICABLE CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. I
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MEAN ROD
SECRETARY OF READ TO THE EXTENT
THAT CLAYTON COMMONWEALTH
ALLIANCE OF LOCALS INLOS
ANGELES WE OPPOSE. SB TEN
EIGHTY FIVE. NINE THREE NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBER FORTY DOLLARS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS WE
APOLOGIZE FOR AT LEAST BETTER
MISSION BUT YOU RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THE BILL THANK YOU.
NINETEEN NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TWO NINE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL
YODER ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO THE
BOARD DID TAKEN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON- TEN EIGHTY
FIVE WILL LOOK AT THE MOMENT
THANK YOU. ONE FOUR TWENTY ONE
ADELINE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS PETER
CALL IN FROM THE COUNCIL
COMMITTEE HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS
IN SAN FRANCISCOTWENTY THREE
HOUSING PROVIDERS AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. NINE ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR MIND IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CAN'T
REMEMBER WHAT THE MATTER THAT
ARE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE AND QUIRK
APOLOGIZED. IN THE EARLIER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A MAJOR SETBACK RIVERA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION ONE SIZE
FITS ALL AND UNFUNDED MANDATES
ARE TERRIBLE WAY TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE STATE
IS LARGE AND DIVERSE AS
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU WE OPPOSE.
ONE TWO FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETEEN
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HOLLY LOFGREN RESIDENT AYE
OPPOSED SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE
INCREASE NEXT THE NINE. THANK
YOU EIGHTY DURING YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ENGAGED
IN HOLLYWOOD FRANKLIN CORTICAL
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS DENSITY
BONUSES DON'T WORK HERE SO GOOD
LUCK WITH THAT. THANK YOU ORDER
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ORDER YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ROBIN RID ITSELF
FROM LOS ANGELES AND MEMBER OF
CITIZENS PRESERVING VANISHED
WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TODAY I
OTHERWISE OPPOSE THAT THE TEN
NINETY FIVE A BASKETBALL THIS
IS TO ARE NOT EVEN AWARE OF
THIS BILL. I AM FOR TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH BILL KAULITZ THE
SPECTACLE LOG BALLY WE ARE
CLOSE THIS IS STILL AN EIGHTY
FIVE. NINE FOUR TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU DAVID LATELY A
LOT PATCHWORK INDIVIDUAL THEY
COLDER AND THE LAKE RESIDENTS
OVER LAKE I ADAMANTLY OPPOSED
HIS BILL BACK TO BE BONUS IS
NOT WORKING FOR A- WEEK. LINE
ONE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAROL
ROSENBERG HARTSFIELD HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION- WE- OPPOSE CAN
EIGHTY FIVE DENSITY BONUSES
DON'T WORK. NINE THREE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR MIND IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE THREE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
IT'S LARA QUIRK IN DALE CITY
COUNCIL FROM THE CITY OF HIDDEN
HILLS AND WE OPPOSE THE SPELL.
AND AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE. THANK YOU
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES. TO THE SENATOR I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
ENGAGING WITH OUR COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL- IN PARTICULAR ONE
JUST HIGHLIGHT- THERE WERE
PROVISIONS AROUND HOW WE
ENCOURAGE MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING AND FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
I DO THINK. THE STATE SHOULD
HAVE A ROLE IN ENCOURAGING
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT THERE WAS.
DEFINITELY A LOT WE NEEDED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE DO THIS IN A
WAY THAT DOESN'T UNDERMINE OR
DISINCENTIVE THE CONSTRUCTION
OF LOW INCOME OR VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSING LAWS ARE PROJECT
YOU BEING WILLING TO TAKE THOSE
PROVISIONS OUT- AND- AS- AS YOU
KNOW. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
MAJOR STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS
AT WITH THAT- WERE- HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION. I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT- AS THE
AUTHOR NOT DISCUSSED. I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU
TO SEE IF WE CAN WORK THROUGH A
SOLUTION THAT MAKES SENSE IN
THIS UP. IN IN THE COMING YEAR.
I ALSO WANT TO JUST TAKE A
MOMENT TO I KNOW THIS BILL ALSO
ADDRESSES THE QUESTION. OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FEE ON
DENSITY BONUS UNITS. THE INTENT
OF THE DENSITY BONUS LAW. HAS
BEEN- QUITE CLEAR THAT THESE
BONUS UNITS ARE INTENDED TO
SUPPORT- THE FINANCIAL
FEASIBILITY OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS. AND THAT THIS
BILL WILL STILL ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CHARGE IMPACT
FEES. THAT BEING SAID OTHERS AT
LEAST ONE JURISDICTION- THAT
HAS RAISED THIS ISSUE.
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD ABOUT THIS I KNOW
IT'S AN ONGOING CONVERSATION.
WITH THAT I'VE BEEN JUST
REMINDED THERE IS ONE PERSON.
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY THAT. IN
PORT. ASK DOT TO TESTIFY.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TORRES WAS STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF UP FOR
GROWTH ACTION CALIFORNIA IS A
CO SPONSOR OF LEARNING ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GUNS ALL IS AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE AM VERY STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT OUR A LISTER ANY
FINAL COMMENTS I WILL TURN IT
BACK TO THE SENATE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU ED SHEERAN Q.
ABSOLUTELY THE BILL WHEN WE
FIRST CONSTRUCTED AT MY OFFICE
MY FIRST CONSTRUCTED IT ONE IN
ADDITION TO THE THINGS THAT I
DESCRIBED TO WE WERE TRYING TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THAT IN SOME
OF OUR AREAS. THE NUMBER OF THE
AREAS THAT THOSE OF US SITTING-
IN THE ROOM REPRESENTS THE NOT
EVERYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT A
NUMBER OF OUR AREAS WHAT WE
CONSIDER MIDDLE INCOME PEOPLE
NOW CANNOT AFFORD HOUSING. AND
THE BEST WE HAVE REALLY
DIFFICULT SITUATION FOR SO EVEN
UNIONIZED WORKERS MANY OF OUR
UNIONIZED WORKERS CERTAINLY
STATE EMPLOYEES AND MANY
OTHERS. CANNOT AFFORD THE HIGH
COST OF HOUSING SAY FOR EXAMPLE
IN MANY PARTS OF THE BAY AREA
SOME PARTS OF SAN DIEGO SOME
NEIGHBORHOODS OF LA. SO WE WERE
TRYING TO ASSIST. AND DEAL WITH
THIS- ISSUE OF QUOTE UNQUOTE
MISSING THAT'LL- BUT CERTAINLY.
I HAVE NO INTENTION OF TRYING
TO ADDRESS THAT AT THE EXPENSE
OF ALL THROUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
LOTS OF ADVOCATES IN GROUPS AND
ALSO WITH YOUR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF IN YOUR GOOD WORK WE
AGREED TO REMOVE THAT THOUGH
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
EXPRESSION OF. HELPING ALL OF
US TRY TO THINK ABOUT WHAT
WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE TOOL TO
HELP MIDDLE INCOME PEOPLE. GET
HOUSING IN THESE HIGH COST
AREAS SO IN WHAT BUT WHILE AT
WORK THAT IT DIDN'T OTHER DAY.
IN ON THE P. ISSUE CERTAINLY ON
I AM MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS WHAT WHAT
WE CAN DO TO ADDRESS BECAUSE
WHAT WE WHAT WE WANT. IS FOR
OUR DB LAW TO WORK. AND WE WANT
BUILDERS TO USE IT AND WE WANT
MORE AFFORDABLE UNITS SO WHAT
EVER WE CAN DO. TO ENHANCE
EITHER MODIFY THIS BILL JUST
ENHANCE WHAT EVER IT'S TWO
WOULD. GOAL I AM MORE THAN
HAPPY CONTINUE TO. AND WE- ASK
FOR. THANK YOU AND AGAIN THANK
FOR A GROUP THE IMMINENCE OF WE
ARE TAKING IN THIS COMMITTEE.
UP WITH THAT IS THERE A MOTION
TO THIS BILL. THE MOTION AND A
BY MISTER BONTA ANA WITH A NOT
A SUCKA PLEASE THE ROLL. DO
PASSED THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
TI<c.cyan> HI CHU I DEEP. SORRY I</c>
DIDN'T HEAR YOU- THE BY GABRIEL.
TIME GABRIEL HI GLORIA KILEY
KILEY HIGHLY MON. BONTA BONTA
AYE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA.
YOU HAVE YOUR VOTES WILL ALSO
WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD
ON. THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM SENATOR. WE HAVE ONE
FINAL ITEM IT IS FILE ITEM TEN
SB TWELVE NINETY NINE-
HOPEFULLY SENATOR PORTANTINO
WILL JOIN US SHORTLY. IN THE
MEANTIME I'M HAPPY TO DO ADD
ON'S IF THAT MAKES SENSE. MADAM
SECRETARY PREPARE ALMOST. WE'RE
JUST GONNA CALL THE MISSING
MEMBERS. WHEN ORDERING FILE
ITEM ONE OF THE WOMAN READ THE
MOTION ARE YES MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. I
FIND MY APOLOGIES SINGAPORE TO
RIGHTS WERE WE JUST GO AND
FINISH THIS FINAL ITEM. SENATOR
FILE ITEM TEN SB. TWELVE NINETY
NINE. IF YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU ARE
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE MEMBER
SORRY I WAS UP IN THE- ASSEMBLY
LABOR AND- I'M OLD AND SLOW.
AND RAN AS FAST AS MY BODY
COULD SO I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB
TWELVE NINETY NINE AND I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LINE IN
THE ANALYSIS AND I THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF THIS IS BEEN A
LOT OF WORK PUT INTO THIS BILL
YOUR COMMITTEE AND MY STAFF TO
THANK EVERYBODY. BONSER WORKING
TOGETHER TO THIS POINT S.
TWELVE NINETY NINE WILL GIVE
INCENTIVES TO CITIES TO CONVERT
ABANDONED RETAIL SITES INTO
AFFORDABLE AND WORKFORCE
HOUSING THE FISCAL INCENTIVES
BUT WE USED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO REPLACE- THE SALES TAX IN
THE FORM OF A GRANT. WHAT I
LIKE ABOUT ROACHES- THE CITIES
DON'T GET THE GRANTS UNTIL
AFTER THE CERTIFICATE OF
OCCUPANCY SO ARE- GIVEN OUT
MUCH IN THE WAY THAT THE
ENTERTAINMENT TAX CREDIT WAS
STRUCTURED IN THAT I'M- YOU CAN
GET THE TAX CREDIT UNTIL AFTER.
YOU SO I'M SURE THE HOUSING
ACTUALLY GET BUILT BY
STRUCTURING IN THIS WAY AS WE
KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS A
SIGNIFICANT HOUSING CRISIS AND
WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF IT AND
THIS WILL GO A LONG WAY I THINK
TO CREATE AFFORDABLE RIGHT NOW
PRETENDED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE. OF
UNFORTUNATELY- BIG BOX RETAIL
AT THE SITTING EMPTY AND THEN
YOU AS- LAND USE GOT MONETIZED
THE SEEKS TO CREATE AN
APPROPRIATE INSTEAD OF AND WITH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE OF. THE RIGHT HIS FACE ON
THE AND I THINK CAN FAVOR.
THIRTY FIVE YOU'RE RIGHT IF YOU
LIKE TO TESTIFY. TO THE
MODERATOR OUR- ALL RIGHT YEAH
OKAY YOU ALL HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
OKAY GREAT HI MY NAME IS JUROR
POLICY MANAGER FOR LA QUE
BUSINESS. WE WE'VE BEEN VERY
BLESSED TO HAVE WORKING WITH
SENATOR. AND IS. AS A AS THE
HALL COMMITTEE. ON THE BILL I
GETTING IT OUT OF PRESENT TO
YOU AND ALSO ARE SO ENCOURAGED
TO SEE THE LOW VOICE AND OF
SUPPORT IN TERMS OF THE SCENE A
FORTY AND SENSE PLAN TO BUILD
MORE HOW THE- SPECIALLY OF THE
WORK FORCE AFFORDABLE CRIME.
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT THE
MISSING OR I'M A LAW OF YOU
KNOW WE SEE A LOT OF EMPLOYERS
EMPLOYEES WHO NEED TO SEE THAT
HAPPEN TO BUILD AND SUSTAINOUR
WALL ECONOMY. AND HAVING TO
HELP WILL BE BETTER. ALSO MANY
SIDE SPECIALLY URBAN. AREAS
BECAUSE IT PROTECT WILL CONTROL.
IT WORKS WITH LOCAL THROUGH
WORKS WITH WILL COMMUNITY. AND
THE WORK OF THE BUILDING. TO
ACT BILL THE NOTHING. HOUSING
THAT WE SO DESPERATELY NEED AND
WHAT ABOUT- WHAT AGAIN THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR HIS HARD WORK
AND EFFORTS ON THIS AS WELL AS-
IS THE CHAIR- CHIU FOR. HIS
LASTED JUST A MOMENT IN THE WAR
ON WERE NOT PORT THANK YOU HAVE
MUCH. AT THIS POINT OUR LET ME
ASK IF MEMBERS OF PUBLIC THE
WHICH. TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF BILL.
THE LADY VENTURA. IF YOU WISH
TO AT THE OF SB. NINETY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE
ALL. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIRMAN. NINE
THREE NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MORE WERE TOP ON BEHALF OF
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS DEVER
CARLTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. LINE FOR THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GET UP TO MEMBERSHIP
CHAIR MEMBERS KARABAKH ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BURBANK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS VANESSA YES
BACCALAUREATE AND I REPRESENT
THE WEST YOU'RE WALKING UP
NORTH PARK AND THE GREAT BIRD
AVENUE BLOCK WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT IT FAIL. THANK YOU
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE SERVER
WHICH IS RUNNING WE CALIFORNIA
CITIES THAT WE ARE SUPPORTERS
MATTER. NINE NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
NEVER NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH I MEAN ROTH
SECRETARY OF RESTOF THE S. AND
THAT CLAYTON COMMONWEALTH
OUTLINE OF A LOCAL REMARKS
ANGELES WE SUPPORT. NINE ONE
HUNDRED YOUR MIND IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS
IS JILL STUART LITTLE
CALIFORNIA WE'RE VERY VERY
HAPPY ABOUT THE BILL AND WE
SUPPORT IT COMPLETELY AND
BILLION WHAT HE'S DOING THANK
YOU. I THREE EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THREE EIGHTY SIX ONLINE IS OPEN.
LINE ONE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAROL
ROSENBERG FROM PARK FEEL
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
SUPPORT TWELVE NINETY NINE.
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ROBIN WILLIAMS FOR
THE MARK DOWN TO US AND MEMBER
PHILIP IN PRESERVING BENNETT
WHAT A SMART CREATIVE BUILD
STRONG WITH THE COURT AND THANK
YOU SENATOR. LINE ONE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY THREE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THEN GAVE
THEM A HOLLYWOOD FRANKLIN
PORTAL COALITION WE LOVE
SENATOR PORTANTINO THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO TELL WITH THE COURT THE
FELT. NINE FOUR OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN LOOKING COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MY HOPE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
MAJOR ASPECT HOLLYWOOD RIVIERA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
SUPPORT INCENTIVIZING INSTEAD
OF PUNISHING. FIND FOUR TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND THE
HIT ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I JUST SPOKE AND
SAID WE SUPPORT INCENTIVIZING
INSTEAD OF PUNISHING THIS IS
AMY JUST AFFECT THE RIVER. IN
LINE THREE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THREE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE FOUR TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH DEFINITELY BONTA
THAT YEAH THAT. THERE'S NO ONE
THINK YOU. GREAT LET US GO TO
THE OPPOSITION ARM I HAVE
LISTED HERE THE MS LANE IS
GOING TO TESTIFY ON THE
OPPOSITION BY UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT MIGHT BE INVOLVING SALAS
YOU SPEAKERS OF. MR YES IF I
COULD I JUMP IN FIRST NOT TO
MENTION SO- WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES AND HAVE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL BE TAKING.
IN APPROPRIATIONS AND THEY SENT
A LETTER SUPPORT- AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED MENDED AND MY
STAFF HAS BEEN BLOWING ME UP
BECAUSE I FORGOT TO MENTION
CATCHER CORRECTED IT SO THANK
YOU GOTCHA ARE YOU TO SHARE
WITH THOSE MOMENTS MIGHT THEY
ARE THE LABOR PROTECTIONS THAT
THEY'VE ASKED ON. A WHOLE HOST
OF THINGS AND I BELIEVE THEY'VE
BEEN SHARED WITH YOUR OFFICE AS
WELL. MISSILE. THERE ARE YEAH
ALL RIGHT I'M HERE. MISTER TO
MISTER FOURTEEN OUT I THINK YOU
FOR THAT YEAH THIS IS THE
PREVAILING WAGE AND SKILLED AND
TRY LANGUAGE THE TWO ALSO FOR
WITH BY NOW WE THANK SENATOR
PORTENT FOR ENGAGE WITH THE
TRADE IN THE SKY. AND ACCEPTING
VERY IN WHEN AND IN DOING SO
THE SIXTY THAT BUILDING TRADES
IS STATE WHY AND SO WE ARE IN
THE OF THIS AS AMENDED WITH THE
LABOR IN THANK AGAIN SO MY FOR
WORK WITH US. THANK YOU. LET ME
ASK THEIR MEMBER OTHER MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC THAT ARE IN OP TO
THE BILL TO THE MY- THE- AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE
NINETY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ALL. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWELVE NINETY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW.
LINE THREE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
RON MILLER EXECUTIVE SECRETARY
OF THE LA ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL I WAS PREPARED
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL BUT I WANT TO THANK MISTER
PORTANTINO FOR DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND TAKING CARE OF
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN BY
PUTTING THE LABOR CONDITIONS
AND- IT- CREATES A PATHWAY TO
GOOD MIDDLE CLASS CAREERS THANK
YOU. LINE FOR THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DID YOU HEAR MEMBERS THIS IS
SERRA FLOCKS IN THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE WERE
OPPOSED TO DISPEL BUT WITH THE
AMENDMENT- BIG THANK YOU TO
MISTER PORTANTINO WE ARE
REMOVING OPPOSITION. FIND THREE
NINETY THANK YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO I'M GONNA
DO IT THIS TIME WITHOUT THE
DOGS BARKING TOM LET ORIGINALLY
IS OPPOSITION NOW SOME FOR THE
SAID THE BUILDING CONSTRUCT
TRADES COUNCIL THANK YOU FOR
THE AMENDMENTS. AND FOR THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I REMEMBER MAPPED OUT
ON THE ACT THE TEAM'S IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL JUST WOULD
LIKE TO I'D BETTER FOR TAKING
THEM AND THANK YOU. I'M THIRTY
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MIKE WEST REPRESENTING
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES NOW IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND FOR
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN MEMBERS
LIKE MONOGRAM UP YEP THE
CALIFORNIA STATE I TRADE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. WHAT'S YOUR
STATE COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN THE INTERNATIONAL
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS UNION
WITH THE MEMBERS WE WILL NOW BE
A SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE FOR
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GRETCHEN IF
SOMEONE BEHALF OF IBEW FIVE SIX
NINE IN OUR THIRTY FOUR HUNDRED
UNITED TO ATTRITION SANDIA
COUNTY THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR
THE AMENDMENT CLEARING OUT OF
COURT. FIND FOUR YEAH IS PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS MAY YES YES
YOU THERE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
CHRIS THEIR WITH THEIR YOU OF
OPERATING WILL THREE WE ARE A
WORKING SPEAK IN OPPOSITION BUT
WE ARE NOW IN SPORTS WITH MEN
WE THINK YOU FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENT AND AFTER FOLKS LIKE
YOU KNOW WORK WITH THE BILL
TRADES UP THAT YOU SHOPS THANK
YOU AND I'LL. ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE OPEN GO. AND ONE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IT'LL-
MAYBE YOU'RE ON YOU. THE TERM
AT THE TIME THERE'S NO ONE I
THINK YOU. THANK YOU YEAH I GOT.
YES WE CAN. YES I'M GONNA FALL
THE REPRESENTING OCCURRING A
MARK ON A GO TO TRADES COUNCIL
IN LIGHT OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN TALKING WE NOW
SUPPORT THE BILL. GREAT OKAY.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISH TESTIFY. OKAY LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES AYE COMMENTS. I'D
SAY TO THE CENTER THANK YOU FOR
TACKLING TO IMPORT AREAS OF
HOUSING PRODUCTION HOW WE CAN
MAKE IT EASIER TO BUILD BUT
ALSO PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO
CITIES WHEN HOUSING GETS BUILT-
CERTAINLY WITH THE FISCAL
ADDITIONAL LAND USE. IT'S OFTEN
HARD WHEN CITIES. DON'T SEE AN-IMMEDIATE ECONOMIC BENEFIT OF
NEW HOUSING- TO WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH DEVELOPMENT SO I
APPRECIATE THAT ALSO APPRECIATE
YOU AGREEING TO OUR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS TO EXPAND THE BILL.
TO COVER A WIDER RANGE OF
WORKFORCE HOUSING AND- BLOOD
WORK DONE AGREEMENT WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES AND WITH THAT
YOU WILL HAVE MY SUPPORT. ANY
FINAL COMMENTS. IT WAS A
PLEASURE TO WORK YOUR STAFF AND
HAPPY THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE TRAITS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I DON'T
PRINT IS OUR MOTION OF THIS FOR.
THERE'S A CENTRALIZED. MADAM SO.
THE MOTION TO PASS AS A TO
ASSEMBLY ON A PRO. CHIO ARE CHU
I DEEP. DEEP I GAVE. GABRIEL I.
KILEY THE MOM BONTA RIGHT BONTA
AYE SILVA WORKS OF I. YOU HAVE
THE VOTES BILL IS A THANK YOU.
IF WE RECALL ABSENT MEMBERS TO
JOIN US FOR A LOCAL.
THE
SECRETARY ONE WE JUST DO ONE
PASSED SO THAT FOLKS CAN LEAVE
IF THEY NEED TO SO LET'S JUST
START AT THE TOP OF YOUR FILE
ITEM ONE PLEASE CALL THE UP
SOME NUMBERS. AT NINETY PASSES
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON A PRO. LEE MON
BONTA. MISS BONTA. BONTA I.
ITEM TWO SB SEVEN NINE FIVE DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. WE
THAT WAS DONE. SHE MUSLIM JUST
CAME BACK TO MONICA FOR ITEM
ONE AGAIN A I THINK WE'RE ALSO
WAITING FOR A GLORIA SO WE'LL
LISTAKEEP GOING AND THEN.
WE'LL CIRCLE BACK FROM IS A
MUCH SO FAR. TO TWO IS DONE
THREE AND- THREE IS DONE FOR IS.
SB EIGHT NINE. DO PASS AS
AMENDED THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON A PRO DEEP. DEEP NOT VOTING
GLORIA. ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT DO YOU
PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
STEEP. DEEP NOW. GABRIEL. SB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. WIENER.
GABRIEL II GLORIA WE- MON BONTA
FUND I. NUMBER SIX SB NINETY
NINE ONE FIVE. MOTION IS TO
PASS GABRIEL. GABRIEL I GLORIA
LIMóN REMOTE I. I NUMBER SEVEN
SB NINE NINE NINE NUMBER. DO
YOU PASS AS AMEND. GLORIA WE.
THE MONA. SB TEN THIRTY TO PASS
AS A MAN TO THIS CAN ON A PER.
GLORIA THE MOM LIMON AYE BONTA.
BONTA I. LIMóN ONLY MISSED ONE
ITEM AT THE BEGINNING OF WHICH
IS FILE ITEM ONE. BUT BUT SIR
TO JUST CYCLE DEMAND I MY
NUMBER NINE SORRY OKAY SKIPPED
HAVE YOU I DO NUMBER NOW AS TEN
EIGHTY TO PASS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLORIA THE
AMOUNT. THE AMOUNT I. SB EIGHT
TEN TWELVE NINETY NINE DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GLORIA KILEY LEE MOUNT. THEM ON
I. THAT'S IT HI GLORIOUS HERE
LET'S TO MORE PAY I THINK
MISSING ON MISSED ONE OR TWO
BILLS IN A CIRCLE THIS A FEW
NADA SURF AFTER EACH ITEM HE
COULD JUST CALL THE FINAL. THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. SB DO PASSED
THE FIRST ONE SB NINE DO. A
MANAGE THE- CA ON A- LIMA. WE
MONO I. THE VOTE IS EIGHT TWO
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT FILE AND
TO. FILE ITEM TO SB SEVEN NINE
FIVE DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THAT ONE'S OUT.
SEVEN TO ONE. FILE ITEM THREE
SB NINE FORTY. THAT ONE IS OUT.
820-514-3899 SB EIGHT NINE NINE
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLORIA. GLORIA
NOT VOTING. SO THAT ONE'S. FIVE
FIVE YEAR OUR EYES THREE NOT
VOTE THE BILLS OUT FILE ITEM
FIVE SB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT SB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT DO PASSED
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GLORIA HI GLORIA
HI. THAT ONE SEVEN TO ONE THE
BILL'S OUT FRONT AND SIX SB
NINE FIFTEEN. SB NINE ONE FIVE
DO YOU PASS. GLORIA GLORIA I.
SO THAT ONE'S. SIX FIVE ONE NOT
VOTING ONE NOW FOR BILLS OUT
FILE ITEM SEVEN SB NINE NINE
NINE SB NINE NINE NINE DO PASS
AS AMENDED GLORIA. GLORIA NOT
VOTING. THAT'S THREE EYES FOR
NOT VOTING ONE NO THE BILL
FAILS AT THIS TIME- SENATOR ON
BURKE IS AS FOR MOTION TO
RECONSIDER. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB FOLLOW NINE SB TEN EIGHTY
FIVE SB TEN THIRTY HOURS
BETWEEN THIRTY SORRY FIVE ONE
EIGHT THE IMPASSE AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY OUT PROBE GLORIA.
GLORIA I THAT UNANIMOUS OUT. I
WAS OUT NOT AS TO TEN A. FIVE
DO PASSAGE A MANAGER THE SOME
COMMAND APPROPRIATE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE THAT'S UNION IN THE
UNANIMOUSLY OUT THE BILL ARE
FILE ITEM TEN FOR ITEMS SB TEN
TWELVE NINE NINE DO PASSES
AMEND TO THE SOME COMING OUT OF.
GLORIA GLORIA I. KILEY SO HE
THAT'S A WHEN HE HAS ON. HAS
HAS BEEN CALLED AS MISTER
CROWLEY COMING TO. OKAY I'LL
HOLD WORLD OPEN FOR FIVE OR BUT
I EVERYONE ELSE IS GONNA. HE'S
NOT RICH OKAY THE WE CAN CLOSE
OLE IN THAT SO FUN SEVEN ICE
HOURS FILER TENNIS OUT.